أتذكَّر كنت في أسبانيا في ذاك الوقت
كان فيه صديق هناك، وقال لي ترى هذا الرجال يبغى يشوفك، وبيجي مخصوص
عشان يقابلك
قلت الله يحييه، وجاء
يوم جاني، قال لي هذا العمل لازم يوقف
كيف؟
قال لي أبدًا، هذا العمل مرفوض تمامًا من المؤسسة الدينية قاطبةً
وراح يجتمع هيئة الكبار العلماء
وراح يصدرون بيان، والعمل بيوقف؛ فأحسن لك وقفه من عندك، يقول لي
قلت له طيب على فكرة
ترى قطر مشاركينا بالعمل، ترى إذا وقَّفته هم بيعرضونه
قال يعرضونه قطر، ولا تعرضه المنحطة «إم بي سي»
هذا «سقراط» من إذاعة «ثمانية» وأنا عمر الجريسي
أستضيف قادة التحوُّل، وقادة الأعمال، وقادة الرأي
ضيف حلقتنا اليوم هو الأستاذ وليد آل إبراهيم
مؤسس ورئيس مجلس إدارة قناة «إم بي سي» أو مجموعة «إم بي سي»
تكلمنا في هذه الحلقة عن توثيق تاريخي
لهذه المجموعة الإعلامية الرائدة في العالم العربي
من التسعينيات؛ مرحلة لندن وتحدياتها والدعم الحكومي
والانتشار العربي إلى مرحلة دبي
والتوسع في القنوات من قناة واحدة إلى أكثر من عشرين قناة
والدخول لعالم المنصات على الإنترنت
ودخول القنوات الرياضية، ثم التعثر والخروج من هذا القطاع
إلى تأسيس قناة إخبارية
بكل ما في ذلك من كواليس واجتماعات مع الزعماء العرب
وأحداث مثيرة جدًا في هذه المرحلة
ثم انتهينا بمرحلة رؤية سعودية 2030
المرحلة القادمة في مجموعة «إم بي سي»
الشراكات مع «نيوم»، مع «القدِّية»، مع هيئة الترفيه
التحوُّل الذي تعيشه السعودية كيف يخدم «إم بي سي»؟
وكيف «إم بي سي» تخدمه؟
وهذا اللقاء صوِّر اليوم في مقر «إم بي سي» في الرياض
بعد ثلاثين سنة من وجود هذه القناة خارج السعودية
أترككم مع الحوار
حيَّاك الله يا أبو خالد، شرفتنا ونورتنا
هلا وغلا، هلا والله
أخيرًا قناة السعودية رجعت السعودية
احنا الآن نصور من مقر «إم بي سي» الجديد
فمكتب مبارك نقول
الله يبارك فيك
حلم، الحمدلله احنا موجودين
في الحي الدوبلوماسي في الرياض
بعد ثلاثين سنة
نعم
وهذا يمكن أهم جزء من حلقتنا اليوم أبو خالد
أننا نبغى نعرف قصة الثلاثين سنة هذه
الرحلة اللي أدَّت إلى خلق إمبراطورية إعلامية كبيرة ورائدة
وفيها كثير من المحطات الجوهرية
فخليني أبدأ وأقول
أيش اللي يخلي رجل مثلك
من أسرة قد لا تحتاج تدخل الإعلام، يدخل هذا العالم؟ أيش القصة؟
صدفة بحتة والله
شلون؟
أنا تخرجت من أمريكا. وفتحت مكتب في الرياض
ما أدري أيش بسوِّيه
ما كان فيه عندي أي تصور ذلك الوقت
هذا 1986 أو 1985؟
تشاركت أنا وإخواني، كان سعود وماجد ومحمد
احنا الأربعة قررنا أنه نعمل شركة ونشوف
بذاك الوقت طبعًا كان فيه طفرة الثمانينيات
بداية الثمانينيات
وكنا نسمع دائمًا ما شاء الله الناس تشتغل
والدولة كانت فاتحة المجال للشباب السعودي
فكان عندك خيارين
إما تروح تشتغل في أحد القطاعات الحكومية
أو الشركات التابعة للحكومة
أو أنك تروح تحاول أنك تعمل شيء
فاحنا قررنا أنه أنا بتولى هذه الجزئية
اللي هي محاولة أنه نعمل مشروع تجاري
فكانت المرحلة الأولى مرحلة فقط دراسة
استكشاف وبحث عن فرص
إيه استكشاف
هو ما كان الإعلام جزء من الخطة أصلًا؟
أبدًا
بس ما كان فيه شيء واضح أو محدد أساسًا
بالصدفة كان فيه صديق، قال لي على مخرج سعودي
قال فيه عنده فكرة
مسلسل بيسوونه
مع ممثل لبناني قديم اسمه رشيد علامة
وهذا أنا كنت أحبه من أيام التلفزيون الأبيض والأسود
وهو يعمل أعمال بالعربية الفصحى
أعمال تاريخية مثل «الأصمعي»
وكانوا يعملون حتى مسلسلات حديثة، بس بالفصحى برضه
ليش بالفصحى؟
أعتقد كان الهدف منها التوزيع
لأن اللهجة اللبنانية يمكن يخافون من بعض القنوات أو بعض الدول ما تأخذها
فيحطونها بالفصحى يضمنون أنه تتوزع على أكبر عدد من الدول
لأن ذاك الوقت ما في قنوات، هي كلها دول
تلفزيونات تابعة لوزارات الإعلام الحكومية
فجاني. أنا طبعًا ما أخذت الموضوع بجدية أبدًا
بس كنت أبغى أشوف رشيد علامة، هذا كان الهدف
فجوني المكتب، وجلسنا
فبعد ما خلصنا وطلع الممثل رشيد علامة
المخرج اللي جاب، قال لي أيش رأيك في الموضوع هذا؟
قلت والله بدرسه، بس أنا أشك إن هذا المجال بدخل فيه
في ذاك الوقت تعرف الميزانية محدودة
فأنت شوي تعمل حساباتك قبل
ما تبغى تأخذ مخاطرة عالية
آسف، كمان قلت له ارجع لي وبدرس الموضوع
وكان عندي واحد جبته مساعد في ذاك الوقت معاي
فراح وعمل دراسة سريعة خلال يومين أو ثلاثة
ورجع وقال لي: «شوف الأرقام اللي جايبينها
من الناحية النظرية صحيحة»
يعني أعتقد تكلفة كانت 500 ألف ريال
والدخل من هذا يطلع حوالي 800 أو 900 ألف، لو كل الدول اشترتها
قال أول شيء، عندك عامل هل الدول كلها تشتريها أو لا؟
هذا غير معروف
ثاني شيء، حتى لو اشتروها، من يدفع؟ ومتى يدفع؟
فيعني أنت داخل في طريق ما نعرف أوله من آخره
وما أعتقد إنها مجدية
فأخذت الصراحة بنصيحته
وقلت للرجال: والله معليش، بس ترى الموضوع غير مجدي بالنسبة لنا
فقال لي: طيب عندي لك فكرة ثانية
ليش ما نعمل، يعني أنا عندي معارف
أو شيء في التلفزيون، وأعرف أنهم في حاجة إلى أفلام وثائقية عن المملكة
وقت الطفرة
وقت الطفرة عن المملكة
وهذه الحقيقة جتني على مكان أنا كنت أشعر فيه وأنا في أمريكا
واحنا طلبة، إنه مافي شيء كان يُظهِر اللي صاير في المملكة
نحن شايفين وش اللي صاير ومطَّلعين
بس لما نجي نحكي مع الأجانب ومع الناس
مافيه مادة عليها القيمة، اللي ممكن يشوفونها
فعجبني هذا الموضوع. وبدأنا فعلًا ندرس الفكرة
وأعجبتني
واشتغلنا عليها، وقلت لهم تمام، إذا بنسوِّيها
ما بروح أقدِّم عرض مكتوب على ورق
أفضِّل أنه أعمل على الأقل فيلم واحد
يبيِّن أحد المشاريع الموجودة، وأحد القطاعات
وأعرضه على الوزارة
مع عرض على المشروع الباقي
اخترنا أعتقد عشرين موضوع أو عشرين فيلم وقتها
وسوِّيت موعد مع مدير المكتب ووزير الإعلام، كان علي الشاعر بذاك الوقت
ويوم جاء اليوم اللي مفروض أقابل علي الشاعر فيه
رحت ودخلت على مدير مكتبه
وقال لي: تفضل، بس ترى علي الشاعر مو موجود
في مهمة رسمية أو شيء
والوزير اللي بالنيابة موجود
الشيخ إبراهيم العنقري الله يرحمه
فأنا شوي انصدمت من الموضوع، لأن أنا كان ودِّي...
تعرف أبغى أحد أتابع معاها
فالشيخ إبراهيم كان جاي موقّت
وعادةً الوزير إذا جاء مكان الوزير الآخر، وكذا اللي كنا نسمعه
أنه ما يأخذ قرارات
ما يشربك نفسه وهو مؤقت
نعم، لأنه ممكن يكون ما عنده خلفيات كافية
مع أنه الشيخ إبراهيم العنقري ترى كان وزير إعلام في السابق
فموضوع الإعلام مو بغريب عليه
وأعتقد أنه عشان كذا ناب عن الشاعر وقتها
فالمهم دخلت عليه، وأعرفه طبعًا
بس سلَّمت وكذا، وقال لي أيش عندك؟
أعطيته الخطاب في الظرف
وأنا حاط فيه الشريط الـ في إتش إس اللي فيه الفيلم اللي احنا صورناه
الفيلم الظاهر -على كلامك- أنكم تعبتوا عليه
نعم، حطيت عليه جزء كبير من رأس المال
بالنسبة لي كان هو أهم نقطة للإقناع، هي أنه يشوف الفيلم طبعًا
الأفكار كلٍ يقدِّم أفكار، بس ورِّينا أيش تقدر تسوِّي
الله يرحمه أخذ الخطاب، طلَّعه، والفيلم موجود داخل الظرف ما طلَّعه
طلَّع الخطاب وقرأه، أخذ قلم وكتب
أنا الحين ما جاز لي الموضوع
لأنه أيش كتب؟ أنا أبغاه يشوف الفيلم ويناقشني
كتب وحط الظرف، ونادى واحد
أعطاه الظرف بالشريط
أنا صراحة
أُحبِطت
جدًا
فسكتت، فالتفت علي
قال: وغيره؟ كيف غيره طال عمرك؟
أيش كتبت؟ وأيش صار؟
قال لي: اسمع، أنا قريت خطابك
أيش كان في الخطاب؟
شرح للمشروع، المشروع فيه عشرين
أعتقد عشرين، ما أتذكر، ما يحضرني الرقم، عشرين أو ثلاثة وعشرين أو شيء، مواضيع أفلام
مثل؟
كل القطاعات
طبعًا الدليل اللي سوِّيناه كان عن الجبيل وينبع
كانت وقتها هي نيوم حقكم
نعم، كان الجبيل و ينبع ذاك الوقت مشروع عظيم
ومغري، لأنه جايبين احنا مخرج أجنبي أيضًا
يعني أبغى شيء يفهمه أكثر
فكان سهل بالنسبة له أنه يفهم الموضوع
و بعدين كل القطاعات
اللي فيها تحول أو فيها تنمية
إيه، تطورت في تلك المرحلة
هذا كان المشروع اللي قُدِّم في الخطاب
نعم
وقال لي: أنا قريت الخطاب
وشفت المواضيع اللي أنت حاطَّها
هذا كافي بالنسبة لي، إني أرفع فيه
هذا القرار مو بعندي، بس أنا برفعه
ورفعت بالتأييد
قلت له طال عمرك ياليتك شفت الشريط
قال لا، اللي بيقرر هو اللي بيشوفه مو بأنا
بس أنا رفعت على المواضيع اللي موجودة
وخلَّي اللي يقرر هو اللي يشوف
قلت له ما قصرت
رفعها؟
نعم رفعها
رفعها لمن؟
هو رفعها للملك فهد طبعًا
بس أنا ذاك الوقت ما وضح لي إنها للملك فهد
وقال برفع فيها
بس أنا أتوقع هي مو واضحة إنها للملك فهد
بس الأقرب إنها تكون راحت للملك، أو رئاسة مجلس الوزراء
وأنا ما كنت أفهم لا في الدولة، ولا أنظمة الدولة
وطلعت وأنا مرتبك أتذكر، حتى «بشتي» نصه طايح
لأني انصدمت من الموقف
وأول تجربة لي مع الحكومة بشكل عام
فطلعت
وأنا قلت أكيد بيوصل إلى الملك
مو بهو اللي شايف الفيلم، أكيد بيوصله من أحد خبر
فنروح له -الله يرحمه- الملك فهد
دائمًا إما أكون عندهم على الغذاء أو العشاء وأكون موجود
وأنتظر أسمع شيء، مافيه!
مر شهر تقريبًا وزيادة
وبديت بيني وبينك
تفقد الأمل؟
إيه
فذاك اليوم كنا نتغذى في جدة مع الملك فهد الله يرحمه
وعقب الغذاء راح قعد في المجلس
وناداني، قال لي: خذ وحط شريط الفيديو هذا في الجهاز
أبدًا ما جاء على بالي أنه هذا هو
قلت بيفتح موضوع أو بيقول لي شيء
أبدًا
بس قال حطَّه
وحطيته
لما حطيته وطلع الفيديو، وتشوفني كيف
وقعدنا نتفرَّج كلنا
ما علَّق، ما قال ولا كلمة
يطالع
يطالع، يطالع، إلى أن خلّص من أول الفيلم إلى آخره
وثائقي عن الجبيل وينبع
عن الجبيل وينبع إيه
الوثائقي اللي أنا أعرفه
يوم خلَّص التفت علي، وطلَّع الخطاب واللي فيه مكتوب عليه من إبراهيم العنقري
وقال لي: أيش أنت مسوِّي مع إبراهيم العنقري اللي قاعد يمدح مشروعكم هذا؟
وكتب عليه، بعدين حط الورقة والقلم
والتفت علي، قال لي: «هذا مشروع ممتاز
ونحن في حاجة له»
وهذا بيُعرض خارج المملكة، في سفارات، وفي أماكن محافل وغيرها
كان ذاك الوقت الملك سلمان الله يحفظه
كان عندهم
يأخذون عن معرض الرياض، شيء للرياض
بين الأمس واليوم
كان يروح يدور في دول مختلفة
فقال هذا احنا محتاجينه هالنوع
لكن أبغى الأفلام الباقية أنها ما تقل عن اللي شفت
لأن اللي شفته جاز لي
فودَّه يعرضه على اللي شافه
إيه
أنا اللي شفته جاز لي، بس الثانيين لا يقلُّون عن هذا
قمت طبعًا قبَّلت يده، والله يطول عمرك، أبد وأكيد
طبعًا هذه خلاص بالنسبة لي
أنه كونه هو عجبه، حتى لو ما أعطاني المشروع هذا كافي بالنسبة لي
خصوصًا أنه الله يرحمه كان ماهو راضي عن
تفاعل الإعلام مع إنجازات وحِراك مرحلة الثمانينيات
هذا قال لي إياه إبراهيم العنقري
إبراهيم العنقري قال لي السبب إني وافقت عليه
لأنه احنا كلنا عندنا مشكلة في أنه الإنجازات اللي تصير ما تظهر
الناس ما وصلتهم بالشكل الصحيح
وبدأنا مشروع برنامج سعودي
المخرج صاحب الفكرة اللي جاني في البداية وقال لي عليها
أنا دخَّلته معنا شريك 20% وقتها
كنا أنا وأخواني الأربعة، فهو الخامس
إنه يكون معنا شريك
في شركة الإنتاج هذه؟
شركة الإنتاج إيه
وأخذنا له أتذكَّر فِلّة في السليمانية
وجاب مخرجين وكروز، وبدأوا يشتغلون
وأظن أني سافرت أنا، أو ما أعرف أيش اللي صار
وانقطعت عنهم فترة، يمكن شهرين أو ثلاثة
فجيت للرياض، وقلت بروح أشوف أيش قاعدين يسوون
طبعًا أنا أكلمه بالتلفون يقولون الأمور تمام
بعض الأحيان يكون عندهم مشاكل في التصوير
نبغى الجهة الفلانية تكلم لنا المسؤول الفلاني
هذا بالتلفون، بس يوم جيت قلت أبغى أشوف، ورُّوني
ففيه شيء اسمه الأوف لاين، يعني اللي هو ما بعد دخلوا عليه الموسيقا
والصورة النهائية بعد
بدأ جاء أول واحد من المخرجين، والمخرجين كانوا من أحد البلدان العربية
فعرض الفيلم، وما جاز لي أبدًا طبعًا
قلت له: شكرًا
من نص الفيلم وأنا متضايق، ما جاز لي
ماهو مثل الجودة اللي في بالك
أبدًا، بعيد جدًا
جاء الثاني وكان أسوأ!
جاء الثالث، والرابع ما صبرت، من أول خمس دقائق قلت له وقِّف
وأنتم جاي لكم تعميد على أربعة أفلام؟
لا، على عشرين
على العشرين فيلم؟
إيه، بس هذه أول أربعة بدأوا فيها، توَّهم بادئين فيها
بادئين فيها مع بعض
والملك كان حاس، قال لك لا ينزل الجودة عن اللي شفناه
إيه، يعني تمام أنت عرضت هذه بضاعتك
لا يجيني شيء بكرة مختلف
صحيح
وهذا طبعًا كلام منطقي وصحيح
هذا ما كان موجود، الشخص المخرج ذا الشريك اللي معنا
ما كان موجود وقت ما شفت الأفلام
فرحت لمكتبي أنا في عمارة الملك فيصل الخيرية
وناديته، وجاء
قلت له: فلان أبغاك تعطيني من وجهة نظرك
لأنه هو اللي يدير المشروع، أنت كيف عامل
تقديراتك على الربح من المشروع هذا؟
يعني في نهاية المشروع أيش تتوقع
أنه احنا بنعمل من المبلغ اللي احنا اتفقنا مع الحكومة عليه؟
أعطاني الرقم وقتها، وأعتقد 10 مليون ريال قال لي
أنه بنربح 10 مليون ريال
أعتقد الرقم الكلي كان 27 مليون أو شيء مثل كذا
يعني بيصرف 17 وبنربح 10 مليون
قلت له: تمام
ناديت المحاسب، وقلت له أعطني شيك
كتبت شيك بمليونين، قلت حصَّتك من العشرة مليون مليونين ريال
خذ ربحك
هذا ربحك، وأبغى بنفس الوقت توقِّع ورقة تنازل عن حصتك
لأني أنا ما بستمر بالمشروع، وإذا أنا سويت المشروع بطريقتي
يمكن ما تربح لا المليونين
يعني السبعة وعشرين يمكن نصرفها ويمكن نصرف فوقها
لأن أنا مو بهدفي الربح هذا الآن
أنا الموضوع صار بالنسبة لي موضوع ببني عليه ثقة مسؤولين كثير
وهذا بيقرر كيف بشتغل في المستقبل
فالموضوع مصداقية بالنسبة لي
وهو كان واضح إنه يبغى يستغل الفرصة بأنه يخفض التكلفة
طبعًا. وشاف فيه فرصة، ذاك الوقت المبلغ كبير
صح
فاتفقنا، وطلع الرجال مشى
ما شاء الله عليه. أحلى ربح بأقل مجهول
إيه، مافيه شك
فجبت علي الحديثي أبو فيصل
كان علي زميل دراسة معي في أمريكا
وفي ذيك اللحظة صراحة ما عاد الموضوع بالنسبة موضوع تخصص في اختيار الشخص
الحين صار موضوع ثقة
لأني أبغى شخص يفهم أنا وين بروح
ويفهم هذا المشروع أيش يعني بالنسبة لي
وينفِّذ اللي أنا أبغاه، ما عاد أبغى منه إضافة
بس في نفس الوقت بنجيب الناس اللي هم متخصصين
في هذه النوعية من الأعمال
وبعطيهم المجال أنهم هم يبدعون بطريقتهم فيها
وجاء، كان علي الحديثي يشتغل مع أخوه عبدالله
الله يعطيه العافية وجاء معاي
وبدأنا المسيرة سوى من ذاك الوقت
ما شاء الله
والحمدلله
أيش صار على العشرين فيلم؟
العشرين الفيلم تنفَّذت على أرقى ما يمكن
جبنا مخرجين من كندا، من بريطانيا، من أستراليا، وعرب بس مبدعين
أتذكر المخرج عدنان إبراهيم الله يرحمه، كان عامل معنا عدة أفلام
طبعًا فيه بعض الأماكن مثل مكة والمدينة هذه لازم يكونوا مسلمين يدخلون يصورون
وربحتوا؟
لا
في هذاك المشروع الصراحة ما ربحنا
بس أنا ما كان يعنيني الموضوع هذا كثير الصراحة في وقتها
لكن بعدين تواصل معاي علي الشاعر -الله يرحمه- وقال لي
عندنا رغبة إنَّا نعطيكم، ونكلِّفكم بعمل أفلام إضافية
انبسطوا من المجموعة الأولى ويبغون يمددون
إيه أعجبتهم، وطلبوا أنه نعمل أعمال
قلت له بجيك المكتب، وأبد اللي تأمر فيه
فرحت له، وأخذت معاي من المحاسب التكاليف كلها
قلت له شوف، أنا بوريك قدامك الحين بشفافية كم صرفنا
وكم كلَّفنا الموضوع، وأنت احكم
على كيف الأفلام القادمة هذه كيف نتعامل معها
فاطَّلع الأرقام كلها
وجاب اللي عندهم في الوزارة حق الشؤون المالية
وقال لهم ادرسوها كمان من عندكم، ودرسوها فعلًا
وتوصلنا احنا وياهم إلى رقم عادل لنا ولهم
للعرض الجديد
وجدَّدنا العرض معهم
الثلاثين فيلم تلك، وبعدين طلبونا مرة ثانية
الإجمالي كان سبعين فيلم
ما شاء الله
اللي انعملت
يوم خلصت طلبونا وقالوا نبغى أعمال إضافية
في هذه المرحلة أنا ما كنت بوقِّف على أعمال وثائقية
يعني أنا خلاص دخلت المجال
فبدات أقول طيب تمام، غير الأعمال الوثائقية أيش بنسوِّي؟
فرحنا نبغى نعمل دراما، بعدين انصدمنا
أو تصادمنا مع أجهزة الإعلام الحكومية في العالم العربي
يعني وين ما نروح، هذولا قوانينهم تختلف عن هذولا
وهذولا عندهم رقابة تختلف عن الرقابة اللي هنا
وفساد في بعض محطات التلفزيون
اللي ما يدخِّلون أعمال إلا يكون لهم مصلحة فيها
فموضوع شائك جدًا
قلت طيب نحن بنوقِّف بس نعمل أفلام وثائقية!
فمن هنا بدأت فكرة «إم بي سي» أو قناة
قلنا طيب ليش احنا ما نعمل قناة؟
ليش نروح تحت رحمة هذه الأجهزة الحكومية
في اثنين وعشرين دولة عربية؟
وبدأت فكرة «إم بي سي»
فقدَّمت لمحمد النويصر -الله يرحمه- خطاب
كان وقتها أيش؟
رئيس الديوان الملكي
قدمت الخطاب للملك، يعني رئيس مجلس الوزراء، أنه احنا نرغب بكذا
ونبغى المباركة، الآن في البداية بس نبغى الإذن
أنكم تنشؤون قناة؟
إيه
بعد فترة كلمني محمد النويصر، وقال لي: ترى أنا عرضت الموضوع
على مولاي، وأنه يقول فيه صالح كامل مقدِّم بعد أنهم يعملون قناة
فليش ما تجتمعون أنتم وياهم وتتفقون مع بعض؟
ما يكون فيه مشروعين مختلفة
قلت: الساعة المباركة
قال لي: أجل أنا برتب الموعد وأعلمك
وفعلًا كلمني أحد من المكتب بعدها يمكن بأيام
وقالوا لي: الموعد اليوم الفلاني تجون
رحت وكان صالح كامل هناك
ما كنت أعرف صالح كامل هذه أول مرة أقابله
أسمع فيه طبعًا، رجل عمال كبير ومعروف
لكن ما قد...
فرق السن بيني وبينه
وأنا توِّي جاي أمريكا ذاك الوقت
فاجتمعنا
وصالح كامل طبعًا فكرة القناة عنده تختلف شوي عننا احنا
لأن صالح كامل كان هو ينتج
عندهم شركة اسمها «الشركة العربية» في مصر
ينتجون مسلسلات
وأعتقد أفلام، بس أكثرها مسلسلات كانت
لمحطات التلفزيون العربية كلها
وفي الأردن كان عندهم استوديوهات في الأردن بعد
بس مختصين ومتوجهين للتلفزيونات الحكومية
فصار عنده مكتبة بأعمال كثيرة
فيبغون هذه الأعمال أنهم يستفيدون منها
بعد ما تنتهي الرخصة للجهة الحكومية اللي تأخذها
ترجع لهم الأعمال
يعني هو ينتج، يبيع على القناة السعودية مدة حقوق سنتين
انتهت السنتين ترجع الحقوق له
فعنده هو مسلسل غير مستغل، يبغى يعيد استغلاله وتدويره
نعم 100% تدوير
لكن احنا لا، أنا فكرتي أني أبغى انطلق بشيء فوق
أعلى من اللي يقدمونه للقنوات الحكومية
يعني أنه على مستوى اللي يقدم في أوربا وفي أمريكا
اللي كنت تشوفه في أمريكا
اللي نشوفه إيه
ونرتقي بالصناعة، وبنفس الوقت يعني الانتشار طبعًا
فشوي هذه الرؤية صارت شوي مختلفة بيننا، لكن اتفقنا عليها بالأخير
يمكن شيء في المنتصف بيننا وبينهم
وبدأنا العمل
تأسست؟ خمسين له، وخمسين لك
إيه، خمسين خمسين أنا وإياه
كان من المفترض أن تنطلق عام 1990
صارت حرب الكويت
فطبعًا أثناء حرب الكويت صعب أنك تطلق قناة
وبنفس الوقت، مسألة كيف القناة
أنا كنت مأمِّل طبعًا أنه الملك فهد
بيعطينا بث أرضي في السعودية
كان على أساس أنه قال اجتمعوا مع بعض
فتوقعت أنه إذا طلعت وشافها
وشاف أنه مافي محاذير أو شيء عليها
أنه بيعطينا بث أرضي
كان هذا الأمل، أنا وصالح كامل كلنا
أنتم وقتها حسمتم وين مقركم، وين موقعكم، ولَّا لسه؟
الاتجاه أكثر على لندن
بعدما درسنا عدة أماكن لا، كان الإتجاه أكثر على لندن
لأنه فيها المساحة اللي أنتم محتاجينها عشان تقدرون تسوون الرؤية اللي في بالكم
نعم، كانت الصحافة العربية في لندن موجودة ومتقدمة هناك
وكان فيه أبحاث التسويق
جريدة «الشرق الأوسط» كانت في لندن هذاك الوقت
فحرية الصحافة والإعلام وذا كانت في لندن أكثر من البلدان العربية هذاك الوقت
فقررت أنها لندن، لكن قلت ممكن نبث أرضي في السعودية
لا، أنا قلت، الحين أنا قلت ما أبغى أفتح هذا الموضوع
قلت بس تطلع، إذا شاف إنه ما فيها محاذير، وإنها عائلية
واحنا حريصين من هذه النحية كنا في البدايات
أتذكر الله يرحمه أول يوم طلعت فيه كان 18 سبتمبر عام 1991
أول بث كان نشرة أخبار
وأنا في غرفة التحكم، الشرفة المُطلَّة على المذيعين اللي يقرؤون النشرة
في لندن؟
إيه، ولَّا، جاني واحد قال لي سنترال الملك فهد
الملك يبغاك الحين
ففيه تلفون في الشرفة، قلت لهم: أعطيني إياه على الخط
كلمني، كان كثير مبسوط الله يرحمه
وقال كلام جدًا فرحني الصراحة
وكانت تقنية تعتبر جديدة؟ موضوع البث؟
لا، احنا كنا نشوف الـ «سي إن إن» في تلك الأيام حرب الكويت
فهي جاية بالساتلايت هذاك الوقت
وأعتقد كان يوجد بعض القنوات الأمريكية تجي من القاعدة الأمريكية اللي في السعودية
وقتها كان لهم بث بعد
فبنشوف بعض القنوات الأمريكية
فيعني مسألة أنك تشوف بالساتلايت إيه
بس طبعًا إنه قناة ومستمرة وتشوفها بهالطريقة لا، غير
وبعدين أصلًا مستوى الـ «إم بي سي» غير
يعني كان الصورة، المظهر، الناس، نوعية البرامج كانت مختلفة كثير
وهي ابتدأت قناة منوعة، يوجد أخبار، يوجد مسلسلات، يوجد برامج عائلية
إيه منوعة
في المكالمة هذه
رميت عليه كلمة، أنه الله يطول عمرك، احنا الآن نبغى نشوف كيف نوصل للناس
بدون ما أطلب طلب مباشر
قال: لا، الناس هم بيلقونها لا تخاف
وراح الموضوع
بعد ما رجعت للمملكة
قلت له: أيش رأيك في موضوع البث، يكون فيه بث أرضي وكذا؟
قال لي: صعبة، في السعودية الآن أنا ما أعتقد أنه الوقت الآن مناسب لهذا الموضوع
تعرف طالعين بعد حرب الكويت، يعني الأوضاع شوية
وقلت له أنا في نفس الوقت طيب دول ثانية؟ فيه دول يمكن ما عندهم نفس الحساسية
قال: مثل مين؟ قلت له: الكويت
بعد التحرير
البحرين، المغرب، أعطيته كأمثلة
قال لي: أنا مستعد أعطيك خطاب وتروح لملك البحرين
أو هذاك الوقت كان أمير البحرين الشيخ عيسى
ولأمير الكويت، وللملك الحسن
أعطاني خطابات، ورحت لهم فعلًا
والثلاثة كلهم وافقوا
وصار فيه بث أرضي للـ «إم بي سي» في أول سنة
في البحرين، وفي الكويت، وفي المغرب
في هذاك الوقت
حتى البحرين فيها ميزة لأنها توصل للمنطقة الشرقية في السعودية
ففيه جزء من السعودية كان يشوف الـ «إم بي سي» هذاك الوقت
طبعًا لاحقًا، أظن بعدها يمكن بسنة أو سنتين
وافق الملك أنهم يأخذون بس نشرة أخبار «إم بي سي»
ويحطونها على القناة الثانية السعودية
وأتذكر الله يرحمه شرط علي لأنه أظن كان التلفزيون السعودي نشرتهم الساعة تسعة
والـ «إم بي سي» تسعة، بنفس الوقت أو شيء
قال: لازم تفصلون بنص ساعة
عشان اللي بيشوف دي ودي يقدر يشوف الثنتين أو شيء مثل كذا
بس حطوها على القناة الثانية السعودية
وإلى هذا الوقت أيش كان نوع الدعم؟
بس فيه قصة الحن طرت علي
على قصة القناة الثانية السعودية، نشرة الأخبار
كان رئيس الحرس الملكي الله يرحمه النملة
مرة احنا في التنهات، في البر مع الملك فهد الله يرحمه
وقاعدين على السفرة، وجاء فريق النملة وقال للملك
طال عمرك أنا بشتكي عليك وليد
قال له الملك: «أفا، أيش سوَّا؟»
قال: أنا أسوِّي دورية على الحرس اللي حول المخيم
وإذا طلعت نيكول تنوري ما لقيتهم
راحوا كلهم قدام الشاشة!
ضحك الله يرحمه
فكنتم مسوِّين مشاغبات
وإلى هذا الوقت من قاعد يصرف؟ من اللي أسس؟
من اللي دفع المبالغ هذه؟ حق لندن والبث والتنقلات والموظفين؟
من كان يدفعها؟
احنا في البداية قلت لك لو أعطونا البث الأرضي كان استمرينا كمشروع تجاري
والدراسات كلها كانت مجدية جدًا معنا
طبعًا لأنه تأخر الموضوع، أو مو يتأخر، أصبح شبه مشكوك في أمره
فبدأنا هنا نشوف أيش الحلول الثانية؟
وخاصة أنه صالح كامل الله يرحمه بدأ يتململ شوي
من الموضوع، وبدأ يفكر في قصة التلفزيون المدفوع
يعني المشفر
وقليل أنا ما اتفقت معاه بهذا النقطة من عدة نواحي
من ناحية أنه الناس ما تعودوا يدفعون على التلفزيون في ذاك الوقت
ومن ناحية ثانية أنه هذا استثمار طويل للأجل
يعني عشان يجيك مردود لازم يستنزف عدة سنوات
ولا كان عندي القدرة على إني أجاريه
في الاستثمار
فبدأنا هنا ننفصل، وحتى وقَّف عن الدفع
في البدايات أنت وإياه بس اللي تدفعون؟
نعم، بس احنا
مافيه دعم من الحكومة؟
أبدًا مافيه أي شيء
فكل التأسيس هذا أنتم وصالح كامل
إيه
وكلما ماهو تأخر في الدفع أنتم غطيتوا فحصتكم تزيد
بالضبط
صار فيه اختلاف، إلى أن بعدين خلاص احنا اشترينا حصته كاملة
وهو راح عمل «إيه آر تي»
بعد هذه؟
بعدها إيه
والله يرحمه الله وفقه بالـ «إيه آر تي» بموضوع الرياضة، لأنه مشرف الرياضة بشكل قوي جدًا
وباعها بالأخير على «بي إن»
وأعتقد هذه رجَّعت كل الاستثمار اللي راح
احنا استمرينا ذاك الوقت
يمكن نقطة التعادل جاءت تقريبًا بعد عشر سنين
من لما بدأت الـ «إم بي سي»
بنجي إلى نقطة التعادل، لكن قبلها أنت الآن
عندك منتج عالي الجودة، وما يوجد اشتراكات
و شريكك طلع
ففيه عندك مصاريف سنوية
لا، فيه دخل، احنا الإعلانات من ثالث سنة بدأت
أول شيء وقعنا مع شركة «تهامة» للإعلان
وبعدين عملنا شركتنا احنا «إيه إم إس»
في جدة في السعودية
كان فيه شوي دخل يجي من البحرين، وقليل من الكويت
بعدين الكويت ثالث سنة وقَّفوا البث الأرضي
ليش؟
والمغرب نفس الشيء، المغرب كمان يمكن ثالث أو رابع سنة وقَّفوا بعد
يمكن شافوا فيها أنها أكلت الجو على القنوات المحلية حقهم
فتعرف عادةً يكون من وزراء الإعلام أنهم يشوفون فيها شوي تحدي لهم
لأنهم عندهم تغييرات وشغلات داخلية، ما يقدرون يعني
وفي هذيك المرحلة أبو خالد، اللي هي مرحلة صعبة ما بين محاولة تغطية المصروفات
ومحاولة صنع منتج ممتاز
صارت لك مواقف مع سفير السعودية في لندن ذاك الوقت
الدكتور غازي القصيبي الله يرحمه
الدكتور غازي الله يرحمه إيه
أيش من المواقف والذكريات اللي تذكرها في تلك المرحلة؟
لأنها هي في مرحلة لندن هذه الحوارات صارت صح؟
صحيح، هي البدايات كلها في لندن
وصادفت احنا أصلًا الـ «إم بي سي» بدأت في 1991
وأظن الدكتور غازي الله يرحمه تعيَّن سفير 1992
يعني في نفس الفترة
بس أذكر مثلًا على موضوع الدعم أنا أتذكَّر هذاك الوقت كنت أشتكي على الدكتور غازي
أنا وصالح كامل، كلنا نجتمع معاه دائمًا في لندن
وكنا نشتكي على موضوع الدعم
فهو كان يقول: غريبة، ليش؟
هو طبعًا ما يحكي فقط عن المملكة، يقول المملكة ودول الخليج
هو الدكتور غازي كان يشوف أنه المملكة ودول الخليج كتلة واحدة
ويقول أنه المملكة ودول الخليج هذولا كانوا ضحية لابتزاز
من صحفيين عرب، سواءً اللي كانوا في لبنان أو في دول أخرى
وكانوا يجيهم معونات كبيرة جدًا من دول الخليج
فاتذكر كان الدكتور غازي يقول: اللي على يدينا احنا في السفارة نعطيهم
أكيد تقوُّم قناة أكبر من «إم بي سي»، وأكبر من «الشرق الأوسط» الجريدة في ذاك الوقت
وحق دول الخليج كانوا السفراء
يقولون نفس الكلام
يعني كلهم متفقين على هذه الجزئية
أذكر واحد من السفراء بدولة شقيقة من دول الخليج
يقول أنه فيه
أحد الصحفيين العرب
كان يهاجم رئيس دولته
في أظن جريدة أو مجلة وقتها
فكلَّفه السفير أنه يتفاهم معاه وكذا
فأظنه أعطاه شيء وقتها
فيقول بعدها بفترة قابلته مرة ثانية
نفس هذا الصحفي
فقلت له طيب الحين أعطيناك، ما عمري شفت كلمة زينة قلتها
ولا ذكرت البلد بشيء
قال: لا، هذا أنتم عطيتوني عشان أسكت
الحين ادفعولي عشان أمدحكم إذا تبغوني أمدحكم!
يوجد عنده قائمة للأسعار
إيه بالضبط
فهو كان فعلًا نوع من الابتزاز
وترى بدأ هذا الكلام من الخمسينات
في لبنان، وحتى أعتقد في مصر
وبعدين استمر إلى الحرب الأهلية اللبنانية عام 1975
معظم هذولا هاجروا إلى لندن وباريس
وكان فيه عدد كبير منهم، طبعًا من دول عربية مختلفة
ترى مو بس من لبنان
بس كانوا موجودين، وكنا نشوفهم في لندن
وفيه في لندن أبو خالد أيضًا موقف ثاني مهم
للأشخاص اللي ما كانوا يؤمنون بقصة «إم بي سي»
وما كانوا يتوقعون أنها توصل اللي وصلته
وكانوا يقولون «اجتهاد شباب صغار يلعبون»
من اللي قال لك المعلومة هذه؟
جات لي معلومة أنه فيه صحفي مخضرم
ماهو شخص عادي كتب عنكم تقرير، أيش القصة؟
واذا ما قلت اسمه ترى أنا بقول
لا، بالعكس أنا أقول اسمه وأفتخر فيه، هو أستاذي وتعلَّمت منه كثير
لكن كان الأستاذ عثمان العمير
هو كان رئيس تحرير «الشرق الأوسط»
رئيس تحرير «الشرق الأوسط» نعم
وأول ما جينا احنا لندن هذاك الوقت
أذكر أنه رفع تقرير أظن
أنه يعني هؤلاء صغار في السن
وأخاف بكرة يعني «يفشلونا» بما معناه، مشروع كبير ومن هذا القبيل
فالملك فهد الله يرحمه وراني هذا، وقال: عثمان يقول كذا
فأنا ضحكت
أكيد ضايقتك؟
لا والله بالعكس ضحكت، ويوم رجعت لندن
رحت نسيت عثمان، ما كنت أعرفه زين
كنت توِّي عرفت طبعًا في لندن أول ما جينا
حتى أيام التحضير تعرَّفت عليه وكذا
بس مافي علاقة قوية كانت بيننا
فرحت ونسيته
وقلت له: اسمع، أنت الحين تقول هذولا ما يفهمون
ترى أنا أؤيد كلامك الحين
لأنه فعلًا هذا موضوع جديد علي
لكن أنت بما إنك سبقتنا في هذا المجال
أحتاج إنك تعلمني من ناحية، ومن ناحية ثانية أنا أحتاج علاقاتك بعد
أنت تعرف ما شاء الله الناس
وما قصَّر والله، شهادة لله
عثمان كان يتعامل مع الـ «إم بي سي» مثلما يتعامل مع «الشرق الأوسط»
والأبحاث أنه مشروع وطني
وطبعًا عثمان بالقيادة كمان بتوجيه من سيدي الملك سلمان الله يحفظه
اللي كان مهتم كثير بالإعلام
وكان يعامل «الشرق الأوسط» والـ «إم بي سي» بنفس الدرجة
ويعطيهم نفس الاهتمام
ويجيني منه اتصالات ذاك الوقت مثلما يجي عثمان أو الأستاذ عبدالرحمن الراشد بعدين
أو الآخرين
فكان حريص جدًا على موضوع الإعلام السعودي بشكل عام
فاحنا نعتبره هو الأب الروحي لنا كلنا
ويمكن من اللحظات الفارقة على حسب ما وصفت لي
أنت في مرحلة لندن العشر سنوات هذه
موضوع «من سيربح المليون»
هذا البرنامج الظاهر كان نقطة تحول في «إم بي سي»
صحيح. هو بداية الـ «إم بي سي» تعرف الإمكانيات على قدَّنا
فكنا معتمدين كثير على مكتبة صالح كامل -الله يرحمه- اللي في «الشركة العربية»
وسوينا اتفاق مع التلفزيون المصري
أخذنا منهم بعد من مكتبة التلفزيون المصري
بعض الأعمال اللي عندهم
وأخذنا عدد كبير من الأفلام العربية القديمة
المكتبة يعني
فكنا يوميًا بعد نشرة الأخبار عندنا فيلم عربي
سبع أيام بالأسبوع فيلم عربي بعد الأخبار
فيلم السهرة؟
فيلم السهرة، كل يوم
وهذا كان هو الإعلانات كلها تجي عليه
هو الأساس في الإعلانات
بعدين أنا شرح لي إياها واحد، أنطوان الشويري الله يرحمه
شرح لي إياها، قال لي: أول إعلانات جاءت للـ «إم بي سي»
كانت ميزانيتها مأخوذة من أشرطة الفيديو
اللي كانوا يعلنون فيها المعلنين في ذاك الوقت
للناس اللي يستأجرون أفلام الفيديو أو يشترون أشرطة الفي إتش إس
فهذه الميزانية الـ «إم بي سي» جات منهم
ما جات من قنوات التلفزيون الحكومية
لأن «إم بي سي» ما تعتبر عندها نسب مشاهدة عالية
عشان الستالايت، الدش، لأنه عدد محدود اللي يشوفونها
فالفيلم العربي نفعنا في الأول
بس طبعًا بعد ما انتشرت الـ «إم بي سي»
وأصبح دخلت هنا على نطاق أوسع من المشاهدين
الفيلم العربي خلاص أُستُهلِك
وبعضه أُعيد أكثر من مرة
فبدأنا نخطط على أنه نعمل برامجنا، وندخل على الثقيل على قولهم بالإنتاج وبالصرف
وأتذكر «من سيربح المليون» كان نقلة مافي شك في وقتها
فالملك سلمان الله يحفظه كان يتابع البرنامج ذاك الوقت
ودائمًا يسألني مثلًا إذا وقَّف
لأنه موسم، هو يجي مثلًا ثلاثة شهور أو أربعة شهور، وبعدين نوقَّفه فترة، ويرجع
فكان دائمًا إذا شفته يسأل: متى يرجع؟ أو إذا فاته حلقة يقول لي أرسل لي إياها
فكان يتابعه، تعرف ما شاء الله موسوعة من المعلومات الله يحفظه
ويمكن المرحلة هذيك أيضًا كان فيها
موضوع ارتفاع التكاليف، ولسه احنا في البدايات
فأنت قدمت طلب رسمي على حكومة المملكة على مجلس وزراء لطلب دعم
صحيح
أيش قصة هذا الدعم؟ وكم جاك؟
أنا قدَّمت لوزير الإعلام، لعلي الشاعر
ووعدني، قال لي أنا بعرض الموضوع
كنتم تخسرون أنتم صح؟
إيه مافيه شك
كان فيه دخل بس كنا نخسر
الصرف أعلى من الدخل
إيه
فقدَّمت أنه نبغى دعم على شكل تسهيلات، تسهيلات قروض مع البنوك
أي شيء يوصِّلنا لنقطة التعادل، لأنه المشاريع اللي مثل هذه فيها تكامل مع الحكومة
يعني أنت اليوم مثل ما قلنا قبل شوي، كم اللي كان يُصرف على
الصحفيين اللي في الخارج هذولا؟
كم اللي كان الدولة تدعم فيه جهات خارجية؟
اليوم مثلًا دولة مثل أمريكا معلنة الآن أنه دعموا شركات مثل «أمازون»
مثل «تسلا»، مثل «سبيس إكس»
جمع أوباما كل الشركات الكبيرة الإعلامية مثل «قوقل» ومثل «فيسبوك» و«أبل»
وصار فيه تسهيلات حكومية لهم كبيرة
وهذا جزء من عمل الحكومات في العالم
فالحقيقة ما قصروا من هالناحية معنا وقتها
وهذا أصلًا كان بان أكثر على موضوع «العربية»
يوم جات «العربية» في المرحلة اللاحقة في 2003 كمان أكثر
واعتمد الدعم؟ وصار يصرف لكم دعم؟
تسهيلات
تسهيلات؟
إيه
تمام، أنا أتذكر سولفت معك أبو خالد على أقسى مرحلة في الثلاثين سنة
سألتك أيش أصعب لحظة عليك في الثلاثين سنة؟
فقلت لي عن حدث صار في هذه الفترة، فترة لندن
اللي هو موضوع الكيبل الأرضي في السعودية اللي وُلد
في نفس تلك المرحلة في 1997 أو 1995
أيش قصته؟ وليش ما نجح؟
تمام، بعد الـ «إم بي سي» طلعت الـ «إم بي سي» مع القناة الفضائية المصرية
كانوا هم أول قناتين موجودة في
وهم سبقوكم، وهذه قصة
هذه مع صفوت الشريف كان وزير الإعلام -الله يرحمه- مصري
رحنا له عشان نأخذ منهم مواد لـ «إم بي سي» وكذا
فأتذكر جايب بواحد جنبه كان يسجل
مثل محضر، ولقاء وكذا. وكنت أنا وصالح كامل الله يرحمه
فكان يسألني صفوت شريف، طبعًا مجاملات وما أدري أيش، وبعدين
هذا اللي يكتب
هو كان وزير الإعلام في مصر
في مصر نعم
ودخلنا على أساس نبغى منهم مواد
ولسه ما بعد طلعت «إم بي سي» هذا قبل ما تطلع
فهذا اللي جنبه بعد شوي صار هو يسأل
وأسئلة تقنية بحتة
طيب كيف بتوصلون للناس؟ هذا الستالايت من وين؟
أيش نوع الدش الاستقبال؟
فأنا شوي حسيت الرجال هذا، طلع مهندس
طلع هو اللي مسؤول عن البث وعن الساتلايت
فبعدها يمكن بشهرين، ما أخذنا إلا مطلعين خبر
تعرف مع الإعلام المصري والضجة
أنه القناة الفضائية المصرية أول قناة فضائية عربية تطلع
طبعًا هم المادة جاهزة عندهم
فقط أخذوا القناة الأولى المصرية وحطوها على الستالايت، وقالوا أول قناة عربية
بس المعلومات كلها آخذينها مننا
لأنها كانت تقنية مختلفة اللي أنتم شغالين عليها؟
إيه، لا لا احنا فيه شيء اسمه «إس باند»
كان موجود عند «عرب سات» ما كانوا يستخدمونه الحكومات
أنتم أول من انتبه له
احنا أول من انتبه له، تقنيًا
فأخذناها، هي كان فيه قناتين بس
فاحنا أخذنا واحدة وهم راحوا أخذوا الثانية
فأخذوا المعلومات مننا وقتها
بالعكس أنا كنت ودي قنوات أكثر تطلع
لأنه هذا يخلي الدش ينتشر أكثر والناس تشوفنا
لأنه مهما كان برامج التلفزيون المصري مختلفة شوي عننا
وأيش علاقة هذه بموضوع الكيبل؟
هذا جاء بعدين، الكيبل عام 1995
أنا شرحت الفكرة للملك فهد الله يرحمه
يمكن بالـ 1994 قبل ما يمرض في 1995 الله يرحمه
شرحت له الفكرة وأيدها تمامًا
وأيش كانت الفكرة؟
الفكرة أنه يكون فيه مثل احنا أخذناه من «سكاي» في بريطانيا
«سكاي» فيه ترخيص واحد في بريطانيا، اللي أخذوها «سكاي»
وصار أي أحد يبغى يدخل الكيبل في بريطانيا
ما يقدر إلا عن طريق «سكاي»
فعندك بوابة واحدة للبلد
وشرحتها للملك فهد، وقلت له احنا ودنا نعمل شيء مثل هذا
هنا رجع لموضوع للبث الأرضي يوم كنت أقول له
يقول لا، مو وقته وكذا
قال لي تمام، هنا ممكن، لأنه هنا الناس تدفع عشان تشترك
اللي بغى يشترك واللي ما يبغى
اللي ما يبغى احنا ما نجبره، ماهي مفتوحة للناس كلهم
فأقتنع بالفكرة
ورحنا ووقعنا مع وزارة الإعلام
ومشينا في المشروع، وكان مشروع عظيم الحقيقة
في عام 1997 أعتقد
كلمني وزير الإعلام، أعتقد كان فؤاد الفارسي في ذاك الوقت
قال لي ترى كان فيه جلسة لمجلس الوزراء
لا عفوًا، احنا لما اتفقنا مع وزارة الإعلام
هم قالوا احنا اللي بنشرف على
يعني يكون فيه نوع من الرقابة
على أيش القنوات، وأيش المحتوى اللي
في الكيبل
إيه يدخل الكيبل
فوافقنا طبعًا، لأن هذا من حق أي دولة
حتى «سكاي» على فكرة فيه عليها
نوع من التحديد أيش المواد اللي تكون موجودة وكذا
حسب طبعًا قوانينهم
يوم كلمني فؤاد الفارسي بعدها بسنتين
واحنا خلاص قد بدينا وانتشرنا
وما عاد باقي إلا نضغط الزر، ونبدأ البث
استثمرتوا وركبتوا
إيه
قال لي ترى كان فيه اجتماع في مجلس الوزراء
وأُخذ قرار أنه «الأوربت» و«الشو تايم»
تُستثنى من الكيبل ويقدرون بأجهزتهم
يسوقونها مثل ما أنتم تسوقون الكيبل
طبعًا قلت لهم هذولا بيدخلون تحت رقابة وزارة الإعلام؟
قال لي لا، مثل ما هم
هم كانوا موجودين في السوق أصلًا
فقال لا لا، هم يستمرون مثل ما هم
يعني يستمرون، وأنتم تعملون كيبل
قلت له ما تركب
أنا هذه القنوات اللي موجودة والمادة مراقبة
ونفس الأفلام ممكن تطلع هنا أو هنا بدون رقابة
من يجي يشترك عندي؟!
هنا انضرب المشروع، وأصلًا الفكرة كلها انتفت
فوصلنا إلى خلاص ساتل منت أنه نلغي المشروع
طبعًا كثير أثَّر فينا الحقيقة الموضوع
لأنه هذا كان معطينا شوي
مثل اللي يقول النور اللي آخر النفق
بعدها «ربَّ ضارةٍ نافعة» طبعًا
صار عندنا احنا مواد، محتوى اشتريناه للكيبل
وعقود مع استوديوهات في الخارج في أمريكا وفي هوليود وغيرها
ما ندري أيش نعمل فيها
كنتوا شارينيها عشان تبثونها من خلال الكيبل والمشتركين
إيه، بس الحين صارت مسؤولية علينا، صارت
عقود موقعين وملزمين فيها
فوالله أرسلنا مجموعة من عندنا
راحوا يقعدون مع كل واحد من هذولا
ويشرحون لهم أيش اللي صار
وقالوا لهم شوفوا بنعطيكم خيارين
الخيار الأول، أنه تسمحوا لنا نبثها مفتوحة
بإعلانات مثل الـ«إم بي سي» هذا خيار
الخيار الثاني، أنه نلغي العقود وندخل محاكم احنا وإياكم
فهي حقوقها اشتريت لتبث للمشتركين، ما يحق لكم بثها العموم؟
إيه، والحقوق ما هي موقعة على خمس سنين
ماهي مثلًا التزام أنك تستمر كل سنة تدفع
خمس سنوات، أيش بتسوي فيها هذه؟
فمعظمهم طبعًا أعتقد
ما يبغون المحاكم
كلهم أو معظمهم وافقوا ما عدا أظن «إتش بي أو»
هذولا اللي فقط يبثون بالكيبل
ما يبغون موادهم تطلع للبث الخارجي، بس معظمهم وافقوا
فكيف تحولت الأزمة إلى فرصة؟
إيه من هنا طلعت القنوات
هذا طبعًا بعد انتقال دبي
كل هذه القصص تبلورت بعد الانتقال لدبي
«إم بي سي2، و إم بي سي آكشن، وإم بي سي ماكس، وإم بي سي فور وإم بي سي 3»
كل هذه المحتوى كان للكيبل بالأساس
اللي إعادة نشر وبث المحتوى اللي انتم متورطين فيه
أيوة
صارت فرصة إنكم تفتحون القنوات الأربع الباقية
وسرَّعت إنه نوصل لنقطة الربحية
لأنه معلنينك بدل ما يعلنون في قناة واحدة
صار عندهم خمس قنوات يعلنون فيها
أيوة
طيب مدام جبت الطاري
هذه انتقالة ممتازة لموضوع من لندن إلى دبي
أنت ذكرت لي أنه فيه أكثر من دولة كانت تبغى تستقطبكم
حتى الظاهر أمير عسير كان يحاول يستقطبكم
ليش اخترتوا دبي؟ أيش اللي صار وقتها؟
لا، هي القرار أنه لندن غالية، فعلًا غالية
وذاك الوقت
أنت تقول لي 40% ضريبة تدفعون صح؟
نعم، الضرائب كانت تصل 40% إيه
لكن في ذاك الوقت الـ «إم بي سي» خلاص انعرفت
وبُثت أرضي في دول مثل البحرين والكويت وفي المغرب
فما عاد صار فيه الخوف
صار عندك سجل حافل
للمحتوى وسياسة القناة وسياسة التوجه العام
فصار فيه قبول من معظم الدول العربية اللي حكينا معهم
احنا وقتها حكينا أتذكر مع
رفيق الحريري -الله يرحمه- في لبنان
كان هو مرحب جدًا، وبالعكس كان يحاول بقوة أنه يجيبنا على لبنان
والشيخ محمد بن راشد طبعًا في دبي
وحكينا مع البحرين وقتها
مصر ما كانوا متحمسين كثير، ولكن ما قالوا لا
ندرس ونشوفهم
فطبعًا مصر كان فيها ميزة واحدة فقط، أنه أرخص، وفيها
عدد الناس اللي نحتاجهم من العاملين في المجال الفني نفسه
فكانت هذه هي ولبنان إلى حدٍ ما هذه ميزة فيهم
أنت تتكلم الآن نهاية التسعينيات؟
نهاية التسعينيات
ليش السعودية ما كانت خيار؟
كنا 2000 أو 1999
السعودية ذاك الوقت، تعرف كان وقت
فيه حرب مع الإرهاب ومع المشاكل اللي كانت صايره
ومع هذا الأمير خالد الفيصل أتذكر
الله يطول عمره، مرة قال لي
خلاص تعالوا عندنا في أبها. كان هو في أبها ذاك الوقت
وأبد أنا جريدة «الوطن» جبتهم هناك
وبنسوي مثل
بطلب إذن أنه نعمل مثل المدينة الإعلامية في أبها
وتكونون ذا، وحتى أتذكر ينكِّت كان يقول ترى
اللي من عرب الشمال، جو أبها بيناسبهم
أنهم مثل لبنان وسوريا والأردن ترى جونا مثل جوهم
بس لا، ما كانت طبعًا جدية، لكن الحقيقة
أكثر اثنين كان الشيخ محمد بن راشد الله يطول عمره
كان حريص جدًا وأرسل مجموعة للندن
كانوا يجتمعون مع كل رؤساء الأقسام
طبعًا يشوفون أيش احتياجاتهم وطلباتهم
كان نشيط جدًا من هذه الناحية
ورفيق الحريري، كان حريص في لبنان
واستضاف حفلكم أو لا رفيق الحريري؟ استضاف حفل عشر سنوات
رفيق إيه، كان مناسبة مرور عشر سنوات في 2001
فقال لي تعال أنا بستضيفكم في بيروت
وحضر الحفل وعملنا مرور عشر سنوات على «إم بي سي» في بيروت وقتها
أيش اللحظة اللي حسمت الموضوع وقلت خلاص بننتقل دبي؟
أول شيء تركيبة لبنان من الأحزاب المختلفة
والطوائف المختلفة اللي فيها؛ ما فيها ضمانات
أتذكر رفيق -الله يرحمه- كان يقول أنا ضمانتكم
وشفنا أيش صار بعدين
فمن هذه الناحية، من ناحية الأمان ما كانت الخيار الأفضل
والحقيقة الشيخ محمد بن راشد كان قال أيش تبغون؟
حتى أنا أتذكر قلت له، طيب الحين عرفت احتياجاتنا، أنت أيش تبغى منا؟
قال أنا أبغاكم تنجحون، شوف إذا نجحتم، ترى أنا أنجح
أنا هذا بس اللي أبغاه منكم
وفي أول اجتماع أنت تقول أنه
من الحوار كان لمَّاح إنه يتكلم عن مخاوفك قبل ما أنت تذكرها
نعم يازينه، هو يسبق قبل ما
مثل ليش؟
أنه والله بكرة مثلًا بيجيك ضغط من أحد الدول
على برنامج، أو على خبر في الأخبار، أو على ما أدري أيش
كيف بتتعامل معاه؟
فصار هو اللي يبادر
يقول أبد احنا عاملين مدينة إعلامية حرة، وهذه منطقة حرة
وهذه ما نتدخل فيها ولا في سياستها
كان كلام حقيقة مقنع جدًا
وأتذكر برضه ضمن الزيارة، أنا شفت المقابلة قبل سبع أو ثمان سنوات
كنت تتكلم على موقف
أنه رحت مع الشيخ محمد لمناسبة مع المجتمع الإماراتي
وكان فيه واحد يطلب وساطة
صحيح
لو تحكي لنا الموقف هذا
هذا كنا عازمنا على الغذاء الشيخ محمد، ومر علي
معالي محمد القرقاوي، على أساس يأخذنا للغذاء لقصر الشيخ محمد
احنا جيناه مرتين أو ثلاث قبلها
طلعنا البر. قلت وين بنروح؟
قال له هذه مفاجأة للشيخ محمد مسويها لكم
يوم رحنا وصلنا لخيمة كبيرة، نزلت
وإلا كان الشيخ محمد بن زايد الله يحفظه
والشيخ محمد بن راشد، موجودين
ومن أهل المنطقة، من القبائل اللي موجودة في المنطقة
عندهم عرس، وحاضرين عرسهم
رحنا جلسنا. جاء واحد حكى الشيخ محمد
بينه وبينه، يساسره كذا
بعدين رفع صوته الشيخ محمد بن راشد وقال
يا أخوان أنا برد على هذا الرجال، بس أبغاكم كلكم تسمعون
أنه الرجال يتوسط لواحد من عيالهم
احتك في بنات في أحد الأسواق في دبي
وأنا أقول لكم الحين، هذا الموضوع ترى ما أقبل فيه وساطة
اللي هو التحرش
إيه، أنه أحد
عاكسهم أو ضايقهم
كانت توَّها دبي بدأت تفتح للعالم
فقال أنا هذا الموضوع ما أقبل فيه واسطة
حتى لو كان أحد من عيال الرجال هذا
يؤشر على الشيخ محمد بن زايد، أو من عيالي أنا
فأتذكر هذا موقف كان صراحة بالنسبة لي
تعرف تشوف أنه وين رايح الشيخ محمد بدبي
بعدها بعد هذه وأخذنا على
ماكيت كبير في أبراج الإمارات بأعلى دور
عنده مكتب الشيخ محمد
ودخلني على الماكيت الكبير
ولوحات وصور خرائط على الجدران
ووراني النخلات هذه اللي بيسويها والمشاريع
كلها ما كانت موجودة ذاك الوقت، ولا نعرف عنها ولا أُعلنت
فكان وراني، وقال مدام إنكم وثقتوا فينا
وبتجون لدبي أبغاكم أول مستفيدين
فورانا وين رايح في دبي
أتذكر طلعنا، وفي المصعد كان أبو فيصل معنا علي الحديثي
أقول له الشيخ محمد حالم هذا، مستحيل يصير هذا الكلام
لأنه شيء في ذاك الوقت ما يمكن تستوعبه
خصوصًا دبي ما عندها بترول أبوظبي
أو مثلًا الإمكانيات اللي عند أبوظبي في ذاك الوقت
لكن كان عندها رؤية، مافي شك
وهنا اقتنعتوا وقررتوا خلاص تتنتقلون؟
لا لا، يوم نروح المناسبة هذه، احنا بالفعل قد بدأنا في النقل
وكانوا معطينكم دورين أو محددين لكم عدد معين؟
إيه، وراني محمد القرقاوي المدينة الإعلامية، كان فيها ثلاث مباني
قال: خذوا المساحة اللي تحتاجون
فأتذكر الفريق اللي معنا، قالوا نحتاج دورين من أحد المباني وقتها
لأنه نسبة اللي نقلوا معنا من لندن لدبي كانت قليلة
كثير من الإنقليز اللي كانوا معنا جلسوا في لندن
كلهم يلقون هناك وظائف
ما كان عندهم مشكلة
يعني ماهم مضطرين للنقل
ودبي ما كانت مثل دبي اليوم
والعرب بعضهم جلسوا لأنهم هذه فرصة لهم يأخذون الجنسية
والجواز، فالجواز يحتاج أظن خمس سنوات أو شيء
فاللي ما كملوا المدة قالوا ما بنروح
الجواز أهم علينا من إنه ننقل معكم
فكم اللي نقلوا معك تقريبًا؟ كم في المائة؟
ممكن 50% أو 60% اللي نقلوا
وكان يكفيهم دور أو دورين، لكن أنت كنت شايف
إيه، فأنا قلت لهم لا. احنا ما جينا دبي عشان نبقى على العدد
أو على القناة هذه
كنا بالفعل طبعًا بدأنا موضوع الـ «إم بي سي 2» و«آكشن»
وبدأت تتبلور الأفكار
فقلت لا، نأخذ المبنى كله
أخذتم المبنى بالكامل وانطلقتوا؟
بالكامل إيه
المرحلة هذه احنا قلنا صار فيها التوسع للقنوات
لاستخدام المحتوى اللي تورطتوا فيه من الكيبل
وبعدين بدأ موضوع الدخل يزيد
وصارت هناك لحظة تاريخية إنه لأول مرة تحققون نقطة التعادل
صحيح
وتزامن معها بالمصادفة أنه الدعم بدأ أيضًا يتوقف من الحكومة
لا لا، احنا على فكرة أول ما نقلنا لدبي بدأ الصرف يقل
أول شيء عدد الموظفين نزل
حتى غير موضوع الضرائب في لندن، احنا جينا بنصف الموظفين
فالصرف قل كثير
والإيرادات زادت مع القنوات الإضافية
والإيرادات زادت، فنقطة التعادل على طول ما أخذت وقت معنا ترى أنه يصير
وهنا ما احتجنا احنا تسهيلات زيادة من الحكومة، فوقفنا هنا
فمافي تسهيلات من تلك اللحظة؟
لا لا، ما فيه أبدًا
لما صارت «العربية» هنا اللي رجعنا وفتحنا الموضوع مرة ثانية
على قصة «العربية» بس
واللي هي جات بعد سنتين من دبي، في 2003؟
إيه في 2003
وأيش قصة «العربية»؟
«العربية» كان اللي فتح الموضوع معاي، كان الأمير عبدالمجيد الله يرحمه
وقتها كنا في مناسبة عنده في البيت
فقال لي ليش الحين «الجزيرة» والـ«بي بي سي» في ذاك الوقت
القنوات كانت تهاجم المملكة بشكل
مبالغ فيه
فقال أنتم عندكم القدرة، وعندكم الفريق اللي ممكن يعمل قناة
على الأقل احنا ما نبغى نهاجم أحد
بس نبغى على الأقل الحقائق تظهر للناس
وهذا دوركم وكذا
فأنا كنت قلت له شوي متخوف من هذا المشروع
لأنه غير تجاري، غير مربح
القنوات الإخبارية في العالم
عندك أنواع، عندك الـ «بي بي سي» مثلًا في بريطانيا
فيه اليوم ضريبة
كل واحد في بريطانيا، مو بس البريطاني
حتى أنت إذا أنت ساكن في بريطانيا تدفع
اسمها ضريبة «بي بي سي»
عجيب!
نعم، فأنت تدفع لـ «بي بي سي» ضريبة سنوية غصبًا عليك
شفتها أو ما شفتها، مجرد عندك تلفزيون في البيت، اسمها ضريبة «بي بي سي»
هذه بريطانيا مثلًا
في أمريكا عندك «سي إن إن» و «فوكس»
و «إم إس إم بي سي» قنوات الإخبارية، كلها عن طريق الكيبل
فهي اشتراك مسبق، بمعنى بالفعل ضامنين الـعائد
مع «كومكاست» ومع «ورنر برذرز» اللي يكون، الكيبل اللي يأخذها
فيه دخل، بغض النظر عن الإعلانات
طبعًا فيه إعلانات، بس هم دخلهم الأساسي من الاشتراكات
وهي أساسية في كل كيبل حتى في أوربا
فإنك تجي تحطها على نفس نظام «الجزيرة» هنا
مثلًا إنها بث مفتوح للناس
خصوصًا الناس ما تدفع هنا على هذا
كنا متخوفين منه صراحة من هذه الناحية
بعدين راح الموضوع، ويوم جاء بعدها بفترة
كلموني من الديوان، قالوا تجي وتقابل الملك عبدالله الله يرحمه
ورحت قابلته، وقال لي علمني
قال لي عبدالمجيد علمني عن مشروعكم
أو ماهو مشروعكم، كيف ممكن ينعمل قناة وكذا؟
فشرحت له
وقال لي طيب، بس ترى أنا ما ودي أنها تنعمل بالطريقة هذه
مثل اللي عملوا القطريين، أو غيرها من المشاريع
أنا أفضِّل أننا نعرض على أصدقائنا في الدول العربية
اللي يرغب يدخل شريك في هذا المشروع، أننا نرحب فيه
وحتى إن شاء الله لو يدخل بـ 1%، ماهو لازم يدخل بنسبة كبيرة
لأنه أنا ما أبغاهم يشوفون أنه هذا المشروع ضد أحد
أو احنا نعمله متوجه بأيدولوجية معينة
أو نبغى نهاجم فيه أحد
فقلت له سَم، مع إني داخليًا ما أنا مقتنع الصراحة
العرب ما عمرهم اجتمعوا على شيء، بيجتمعون على قناة بعد!
ومن بيديرها؟ كيف بكرة بيصير هذا المجلس؟
بس طبعًا قلت له سمع وطاعة، أبد أبشر
ورحت قابلت أتذكَّر مجموعة منهم في ذلك الوقت
الشيخ صباح رحَّب، وأتذكر قال لي أيش الاستثمار وكذا؟
قلت والله احنا حاطين مبدئيًًا
10% الحصة على عشر حصص
على أساس ممكن عشر دولة أو كل واحد يأخذ
قال لي أبغى حصتين، أنا أدخل بـ 20%
وكان وزير الإعلام وقتها الشيخ أحمد الفهد، كان معنا في الاجتماع
ما قصرت
وأتذكر رحت لعلي عبدالله صالح في اليمن وقتها
وشرحت له الموضوع قال لي على خشمي، بلغ الملك عبدالله أنا أول واحد
بعدين التفلت علي، وقال لي بس المملكة تدفع
طيب هي 10%
إيه هي 10% بس أنتم ادفعوا
ورحت وزرت كذا واحد، ورفيق الحريري طبعًا رحَّب كثير
كان هو رئيس وزراء لبنان وقتها، أنه يدخل فيها
ومعمر القذافي؟ ولَّا ما تبغى تقولها؟
معمر قصته شوي مختلفة، لأنه معمر
أنا طلبت موعد
صادفت أنه الموعد اللي أعطوني إياه، هم أعطوني إياه قبله بشهر يمكن
أنه بعد قمة «شرم الشيخ»
قمة «شرم الشيخ» صار فيها الاحتكاك بين الملك عبدالله وبين معمر
فأنا رحت على الموعد
مبرمج وكذا في دبي، وحتى ما كنت مركز على موضوع اللي صار
فيوم رحت له، أثر رجال مليان على المملكة وعلى الملك عبدالله
ويوم خلصنا الاجتماع «العربية» وما «العربية»
قال طيب، بس يا إخوان لو سمحتوا اطلعوا
اللي معاي كلهم طلعهم. قعدت أنا وإياه لحالنا
فجلست أنا وإياه لحالنا
طلع بالكلام تمامًا عن قصة «العربية» وقصة القناة
ودخل في موضوع الخلاف اللي بينه وبين الملك عبدالله
فأنا قلت له، هذا ما هو اختصاصي
وأنا ما أعمل في الحكومة السعودية، ولا لي أي علاقة في هذا الموضوع
ويمكن أحسن هذا يكون فيه قناة مشتركة بينكم
سواءً من خلال السفير، أو من خلال الوزراء اللي يتعاملون معكم
قفلت معه الموضوع
أيوه، وطلعت من عنده واحنا طلعنا ندور السلامة
ما تنلامون والله
وتشكلت المفروض إنها قناة «العربية» اللي تجمع كل هذولي
لكن فعليًا ما صار شيء
أنتم انطلقتوا بتمويل ذاتي وبدأتوا 2003؟
إيه، هي بدأت تمويل من الـ«إم بي سي»
من الـ«إم بي سي»
وعلى أساس كان المفروض أنه الكويت معنا
الكويت صار فيه خلاف بسيط في بداية البث
كان بدأ الغزو الأمريكي على العراق في ذاك الوقت
في 2003 صحيح
إيه 2003
كانت تزامنت انطلاق «العربية» مع بداية الغزو
فكنا احنا آخذين التسمية اللي الأمم المتحدة اطلقتها
إنه الغزو، «غزو العراق»
فالكويت كانوا يسمونه «حرب التحرير»
يعني تحرير العراق من صدام ومن
فقالوا لنا لا، لازم تغيرون العنوان
إنكم تخلونه «حرب التحرير» على الكويت
وأنا ما ألوم الكويت طبعًا من اللي مروا فيه
ولكن احنا ما نقدر نطلع خارج السياق اللي الأمم المتحدة
تستخدمه
إيه، فصار هذا الخلاف
بعدين قالوا بننسحب أجل احنا من الموضوع، وانتهى الموضوع، وأكملنا احنا
وصارت فقط السعودية هي اللي خلف القناة؟
في البداية الـ «إم بي سي»
الـ «إم بي سي»؟
إيه
يمكن من اللحظات المهمة أيضًا
أقصد اللحظة المعنوية مهمة في مرحلة «إم بي سي» دبي
إنها أُقيمت مناسبة أنت دعيت الدكتور غازي القصيبي الله يرحمه
عندك في البيت بحضور مجموعة وقال
لما كنت سفير في لندن، جاء شاب صغير يحمل معه حلم كبير
وتكلم بشكل فيه إشادة كبيرة لتجربتكم
وأتذكر كُتب مقال على هذا الموضوع. ومنها أخذت أنا السالفة هذه
فودي تعطينا أيش قصة المناسبة هذه؟
لا أبدًا هو الدكتور غازي كان وزير وقتها
وكان جاي في مهمة رسمية في أبوظبي
وطبعًا بيننا صداقة، وبيننا عِشرة أيام لندن
فكلمنا قبل ما يجي، قال أنا بروح لأبوظبي
بس بالليل آتي وأتعشى معكم
وجمعنا نفس الشلة تقريبًا اللي كانوا في لندن، كانوا موجودين
استمتعنا معاه الله يرحمه
ترى كانت هذه آخر مرة أشوفه فيها، بعدها سافر لأمريكا للعلاج
الله يغفر له ويرحمه
وفي نفس هذيك الفترة برضه، بدأت موضوع «شاهد» 2011
لا، 2008
2008؟
نعم، بداية «شاهد» كانت 2008
«شاهد» مفتوح، كان اللي يسمونه «كاتشب»
اللي هو مواد التلفزيون نفسها يلقونها الناس
اللي فاته عمل مسلسل أو برنامج، ويقدر يشوفه في فترة لاحقه
وبدأناه 2008. وذلك الوقت ما كان
صحيح «نتفلكس» كانت بداياتها، والتقنية بدأت تظهر
لكن المدفوع أنه الإنترنت ما كان بالقوة اللي صار فيها بعدين
فترددنا في مسألة أنه يكون مدفوع، أو أننا نستثمر ونحط فيه رأس مال
مع أنه أنا أتذكر
في مجلس إدارة الـ «إم بي سي» يمكن على 2011-2012
كان معانا، والله يمكن 2012
كان من أعضاء مجلس الإدارة في ذاك الوقت
محمد عبداللطيف جميل وخالد الملحم
كانوا يميلون إلى الاستثمار في «شاهد» المدفوع
كان «نتفلكس» بدأت تظهر على السطح
وكانت «إم بي سي» تدفع توزيع
تعطينا أرباح في ذلك الوقت
فكانوا يقولوا من بدل ما توزع أرباح على الشركاء
حطها في «شاهد» ذاك الوقت
الإدارة ما كانوا متحمسين كثير الصحيح وقتها
بدأنا الاستثمار في «شاهد» 2020
قعدتوا 12 سنة عشان تؤمنون بالموضوع؟
لا، هو إلى الإنترنت وصل بالشكل
اللي يعني خلاص، صار فيه ثقة أنك تحط ثقل عليه
و«نتفلكس» يمكن غيَّرت سلوك الناس
وعرَّفتهم أكثر على هذا النموذج أو لا؟
صحيح، وطلع «أمازون»
بدأ التدفق يكون أوضح
2020 كنا محظوظين أنه بدأنا مع بداية الوباء
مع بداية كورونا
كان احنا بدأنا في يناير
وكورونا صارت أظن في شهر 3 أو 4 من نفس السنة
مارس إيه
فصار الإنغلاق في معظم الدول العربية
وهذا ساعد في انتشار الاشتراكات
وانتشار «شاهد» بشكل ممتاز مرة بالنسبة لنا
أتذكر في رمضان
من 100 ألف في رمضان وصل مليون
هذا على طول في أول خمس أو ستة شهور
أنا كنت واحد منهم، أنا أول مرة اشتركت ودفعت
كانت في رمضان 2020 وقت الجائحة
فهي اللي كانت لحظة الانطلاقة لـ «شاهد»
وبنسولف شوي عن «شاهد»، بس أنا برجعك للتسعينيات
وأقولك ضيعت 200 مليون دولار
ولها علاقة هذه بـ «شاهد» نوعًا ما
أيش قصة الـ 200 مليون اللي ضاعت؟
احنا ذيك الأيام اشترينا الـ «يونايتد برس انترناشيونال» منBankruptcy CourCourt
هذه في التسعينيات صح؟
في آخر 1991 بداية 1992
كانت مفلسة
كانت مفلسة في المحكمة، ولقيناها فرصة
و 4 مليون دولار، ولا شيء وقتها
طبعًا بعدين اكتشفنا إنه في وراه مسؤولية كبيرة
أنه الموظفين كانوا مرتبطين بالاتحاد
واحنا ما كنا فاهمين قصة هذا
اتحاد العمال في أمريكا، وكيف يشتغل، وأنك ما تقدر تفصل أحد
فكان فيه عدد كبير من المكاتب الصغيرة
في كل قرية في أمريكا وكل مدينة لـ «يو بي آي»
فيها موظفين ما تقدر تفصلهم
طبعًا هؤلاء عبء كبير على التشغيل، على الشركة
المهم، أنه في «البيت الأبيض» في أمريكا عندهم
أي رئيس أمريكي جديد؛ صحفيين «البيت الأبيض»
يدعونه في مناسبة على عشاء في حفل يسمونه «قريد آيرن كلوب»
في هذا الحفل يجي الرئيس يحضر
واللي يكون يدعي للحفل، وهو اللي يكون
رئيس الصحفيين «البيت الأبيض» هي بالنيابة
كل واحدة من وسائل الإعلام الأمريكية
يحطون مندوبهم في «البيت الأبيض» يكون رئيس لفترة معينة
بعدين يجي اللي بعده واللي بعده كذا، يتناوبون عليها
على حظنا بالصدفة، تلك المرة كانت هيلين توماس
مراسلة الـ «يو بي آي» في «البيت الأبيض»
هي رئيسة صحفيين «البيت الأبيض»
فهي بالعُرف تدعي رئيسها هي، اللي أنا كان في ذاك الوقت
يجلس جنب الرئيس كلينتون
فرحت حضرت الحفل
كانت فرصة طبعًا بقعد جنب الرئيس كلينتون
وجلست وقعدت وسولفت أنا وإياه
طبعًا هم معطينه عني خلفية، وعن الـ «إم بي سي» و الـ «يو بي آي» وكذا
فقال لي أنا مستغرب أنت ليش تستثمر بالشغلات هذه؟
خصوصًا أنت توَّك بادي جديد، كانت أول سنة لنا
صحيح
ترى فيه شي اسمه إنترنت
ترى الحين احنا أطلقناه
وترى الإنترنت الآن كان أول للاستخدام العسكري
الآن صار للعامة، يعني للناس
وهذا هو الإعلام الجديد، وهو المستقبل
والطريق السريع
كان يشرح شرح كامل وعاطفي
كان هو بالنسبة له هذا مشروع
طبعًا من الانتخابات هو كان يتكلم عنه
و«ألقور» اللي أطلقه وقتها
فوقتها «ياهو» كانوا طالبين من «يو بي آي»
أنهم يأخذون اسم «يو بي آي» يحطونه على صفحة الأخبار في «ياهو»
ويدفعون لـ «يو بي آي» مقابلها مليونين دولار، عبارة عن أسهم في «ياهو»
فالرئيس اللي كان ماسك الـ «يو بي آي» وقتها رفض العرض
طلب أكثر أو شيء مثل هذا
«ياهو» طبعًا في ذاك الوقت و «أمريكا أون لاين»
قبل «قوقل» وقبل «فيس بوك» قبل هذولا كلهم
«ياهو» و«أمريكا أون لاين» طلعوا مثل الصاروخ
اللي سموه «دوت كوم بابل»
فكل سنة أنا أشوف المليونين دولار هذه كل مالها تطلع إلى أن وصلت 200 مليون
على 1999 وصلت 200 مليون الأسهم نفسها اللي كان قيمتها مليونين
فلو إنك أخذتها كان لا سويت «إم بي سي»
وكان ما خسرنا شيء، ترى بس يحطون اسم «يو بي آي»
بس قصر نظر من الإدارة اللي كانت موجودة وقتها صراحة
رزق ما كُتب لك
إيه بالضبط
ونرجع لفترة «إم بي سي» دبي
اللي كانت فيها «العربية» جالسة تتشكل وبدأت وأخذت خط تحرير
ودي أفهم أيش طبيعة العلاقة بين «إم بي سي»و «العربية»؟
أيش موقع الحكومة السعودية في «العربية»؟
هل تتدخلون أنتم في التحرير؟ أم لها تحرير مستقل؟
ودي أفهم هذه أكثر
الملك عبدالله -الله يرحمه- يوم سألني عن «العربية»
بعد ما الأمير عبدالمجيد حكى معه وقتها وجلست معه
يوم سألني عن «العربية» قال: أنتم من وين بتجيبون الناس؟ وكيف بتسوونها؟
قلت له أنت تشوف أخبار الـ «إم بي سي»؟
قال لي إيوة
قلت خلاص شوف ترى هؤلاء اللي عاملين أخبار «إم بي سي»
ترى نفس غرفة الأخبار هذه هي اللي بتكون «العربية»
احنا جابرينهم بـ «إم بي سي» إنهم ما يسوون
إلا كان أول شيء نشرتين، وبعدين نزلناها إلى نشرة واحدة
لأنه احنا قناة منوعة
بس أنا لو قلت لهم روحوا الآن اعملوا قناة
ترى ما بيكون عندهم مشكلة، يمكن يضيفون بعض الصحفيين وبعض الموظفين زيادة
بس ما عندهم مشكلة أنهم يعملونها
فإذا أنت عاجبتك أخبار الـ «إم بي سي»، ترى ما بتكون مختلفة كثير عنها
قال لي لا ممتاز، عال أخبار الـ «إم بي سي»
قلت له طال عمرك ترى ما بتختلف كثير عنها وقتها
طبعًا احنا علاقتنا مع الحكومة السعودية علاقة تكامل
يعني ما عمره الحكومة السعودية تدخلت في
إنه والله هذه خطوط لا تتعدونها
هذا ما أدري أيش ينقال، وهذا ما ينقال
بس طبعًا الصحفيين اللي موجودين والناس اللي يعملون
كلهم عندهم الخبرة وعندهم التجربة وعارفين
حدود
لا، فيه خط لازم يكون عندك خط
أنت أيش اللي يميزك؟
كل واحد له خط ماشي عليه
أذكر فيه موقف قال لي إياه الوزير
الدكتور عبدالعزيز خوجه يوم كان وزير إعلام
في مرة من المرات كان جالس عند الملك عبدالله
وطلع على «العربية» خبر مقابلة مع عبدالحليم خدَّام
في ذاك الوقت كان انقلب على الحكومة وعلى بشار الأسد والحكومة السورية وقتها
وطلع الخبر، طبعًا كان الخبر كبير ومجلجل وعظيم
كان ليلة رأس السنة
فيقول أنا كنت في المجلس عند الملك
الملك يتفرج وكلنا نتفرج ورفع الصوت
فيقول أنا ما عندي شك ولا واحد في المليون
أنه الملك عارف عن الموضوع، يعني الموضوع مرتب
يقول طلعت كلمت حق التلفزيون السعودي قلت خذوا «العربية» هذا وحطوه عندكم
لأنه هذا موقف دولة، قصدي كبير
فراحوا وطلعوه في التلفزيون السعودي
يقول ما أخذت إلا أثر أحد يتكلم مع الملك وبلغ الملك
يقول ويعصِّب الملك الله يرحمه عليه
أنت مهبول؟
أنت تخلينا احنا نأخذ موقف ضد بلد عربي ثاني
أيش دخلك في ذا الموقف؟
قال والله أنا معي اجتهاد واجتهاد خاطئ
الملك الله يرحمه، سواءً الملك فهد أو الملك عبدالله
ما ينظرون للي يطلع في الـ«إم بي سي» أو «العربية»
أنه يُمثل رأي الحكومة السعودية
هي علاقة تكامل
فيه شيء، فيه وجهات نظر، فيه شغلات يهمهم إنها تطلع مثلًا
نتواصل فيها مع بعض المسؤولين
ونظهرها بالشكل اللائق والمناسب في حال أُخذت مواقف معينة
لكن مافي شيء اسمه طلِّع هذا ولا تطلِّع هذا
لكن ماهو سر أنه الحكومة السعودية تملك في قناة «العربية» أو لا؟
وأنتم تملكون وتشاغلون
لا، احنا العلاقة بيننا تسهيلات
في حال إنه ما كان فيه دخل تجاري كافي
الفكرة كلها أنه الـ «إم بي سي» و«العربية» مستقلة تمامًا
وتجارية بحتة في حال أنه توفر جانب الدخل التجاري
فاللي يصير أنه بعض الأحيان يصير فيه تسهيلات
إلى أن يكون فيه دخل كافي
للإستدامة عشان تستمر
للإستدامة نعم
أتذكر
لأنه أي دعم ما هو مستمر
ترى أي دعم ما يمكن تستمر عليه إلى الأبد
فأنت من واجبك أنت إنك في يوم من الأيام توصل إلى الربحية
وتوصل إلى أنك حتى تكبر من خلال
التشغيل التجاري للمشروع
في نفس ذيك الفترة الأمير وليد بن طلال بدأ قناة الأخبارية اللي هي قناة «العرب»
وكان تموضعها أو وصفه لها بأنه
«الجزيرة» قناة الشعوب، «العربية» قناة الحكومات، «العرب» نبغاها في النص
كذا كان يصف التموضع
هل هذا تموضع «العربية» صحيح؟
أبدًا، بالعكس اليوم «العربية» واصلة للشعوب
أكثر من أي قناة عربية ثانية
كيف؟
نسب مشاهدة «العربية» اليوم في العالم العربي أكبر من أي قناة ثانية
يعني «العربية» و «الحدث»، حتى «الحدث»
احنا يصير عندنا مشكلة بعض الأحيان مثلًا أعطيك مثال
مثلًا أحداث السودان
«العربية» كرَّست كل البث للسودان مثلًا، للأحداث اللي صارت
كان فيه مشكلة لأنه الناس تعتمد على «العربية»
في تغطية الأخبار لأسواق المال في فترة افتتاح السوق
كان تجينا شكاوي كثير من الناس
أنه طيب الحين رحتوا للسودان وين احنا؟
نبغى «العربية» ونبغى التحليل
فبالعكس «العربية» قناة الشعوب بالدرجة الأولى
ومرحلة أيضًا دبي كان فيها التوسع لقنوات الدول
احنا شفنا قنوات التخصص أو المجال
اللي هي قناة أفلام، قناة أطفال، هذه حكينا قصتها
لكن أيضًا بدأتوا في موضوع قنوات الدول
«إم بي سي مصر»، «إم بي سي العراق»، «إم بي سي فارس»
أيش السر؟
هذه جغرافيا، بالنهاية أنت اليوم المطلوب أنك تكون
اللي يسمونه «بانارب» اللي هي القنوات اللي تبث على العالم العربي كله
ما عاد صارت تقدر تنافس القنوات المحلية
لأنه الناس يبغون أخبارهم، يبغون شؤونهم
لهجتهم، مواضيعهم
ثقافتهم. فهذا ما تقدر أنت تعمله على كل الدول العربية بنفس الوقت
فرحنا إلى أنه لا، كل منطقة يكون لها قناة خاصة فيها
ولكن فيه محتوى يمكن يشكل 50% أو 60% مشترك
اليوم مثلًا إذا عملت
مسلسل ضخم أو عملت عمل معين؛ بيكون يشوفونه كلهم
أو مثلًا برنامج مثل «ذا فويس» أو «مواهب العرب»
أو «حكاية وعد»
أو «حكاية وعد»، هذا تلقاهم يشوفونه في كل
على فكرة على طاري «حكاية وعد»
أنا أهنيك على البرنامج
تسلم، والله يجزاك خير
الحقيقة أنا أفتخر أنه «حكاية وعد» كانت موجود على الـ«إم بي سي» في رمضان
وأهنيك على تعمقك في موضوع الرؤية
اليوم ما شاء الله أنت مرجع في هذا الموضوع
وأنا ما أمدحك في وجهك ترى أنا أقول وراءك دائمًا
شكرًا لثقتك وللمساحة اللي أعطيتني إياها
والـ «إم بي سي» ترى تفتخر أنك تكون موجود فيها
وأنه أحمد الشقيري موجود فيها، وأنه الشباب السعوديين اليوم
فعلًا نفتخر فيهم وانتشارهم على العالم العربي كله مو بس في بلدانهم
تسلم شهادة اعتز فيها، الله يعطيك العافية
في نفس فترة دبي دخلتوا على ملف مرة مثير
وهذا الملف يستمر في الإثارة إلى الآن ما أحد برَّد أكبادنا
موضوع القنوات الرياضية
عام 2014 أنتم فزتوا في حقوق نقل «الدوري السعودي»
وكان العقد 10 سنوات
بتكلفة حدود 3.6 مليار ريال على 10 سنوات طبعًا
صحيح
لكن ما كملتوه! أيش اللي صار؟
أبدًا، هو كان قرار من الاتحاد السعودي لكرة القدم
احنا اتفاقنا مع الاتحاد السعودي
قرروا إنهم ينتظرون على التشفير
يعني يمدون فترة البث المفتوح
واحنا غير مجدي بالنسبة لنا
شوف اليوم النقل التلفزيوني في العالم كله
هو نقل مشفر وبإشتراكات
لأنه الحقوق أصبحت مرتفعة جدًا لشراءها من قِبل المؤسسات الإعلامية
ما بالك
أيش اللي رفعها؟ أيش اللي اختلف؟
لا لا، في العالم هي مرتفعة
بس أضرب اللي صار في العالم بعشرة في منطقتنا
منطقتنا الارتفاع غير منطقي وغير مجدي
وأنا أتكلم عن الحقوق العالمية مثل الـ «دوري الأبطال»، الـ«الدوري الإنقليزي الممتاز»
كل الدورات المهمة الأوربية، أصبحت أسعارها فلكية
أنا بعطيك مثال
«دوري الأبطال» «أم بي سي» أخذته 5 سنوات
أعتقد من 1995 أو 1996 إلى 2000 أو 2001
كنا ندفع 5 مليون دولار في السنة
عجيب! وهذه للبث في العالم العربي
كل العالم «مينا» الشرق الأوسط وشمال أفريقيا
اليوم تعدى 250 مليون دولار
طيب ما فيه أي مبرر ينقله من هنا إلى هنا
لو تشوف نفس -خلنا نقول- «دوري الأبطال» في بريطانيا
خذ بنفس الفترة هذيك والآن، ما بتشوف التباين في الأسعار هذا
بس صار فيه -خلنا نقول- مال حكومي، مال سياسي دخل في شراء الحقوق
وألغى العملية التجارية في الموضوع
بالنسبة للدوري السعودي، احنا عملنا دراساتنا على التشفير
يوم اُتخذ القرار من الاتحاد السعودي بلغونا
أنه لا نبغى نأجل التشفير، ألغينا الاتفاق
وصار فيه تسويه معهم على المدة أو الخسارة اللي احنا خسرناها
وانتهى الموضوع وقتها
ومن ذاك الوقت أو المهتمين بالشأن الرياضي، يقولون من بعد «إيه آر تي»
ما جاتنا أي لحظة نتابع الدوري حقنا اللي هو أقوى دوري عربي
ومن الأهم عالميًا بشكل مُرضي
اليوم بسألك كمختص في الإعلام ما هو كرئيس «أم بي سي»
ليش ما احنا قادرين ننجح في صنع قناة رياضية
توازي اسم المملكة، قدرات المملكة
تميُّز الدوري حقنا، حجم المشاهدات في الدوري؟
والله أنا أختلف معك في مسألة أنه
الـ «بروسبورت» اللي احنا عملناه إنها ما كانت مرضية
أنا أعتقد الـ «بروسبورت» كان نقلها نقل ممتاز
ولكن طبعا عادةً عشان توصل للجودة اللي اليوم أنت تشوفها في أوربا
في «بي إن»
حتى «بي إن»
التكاليف تكون أعلى بكثير
يعني أنت هذه تعتمد على الاشتراكات، وتعتمد على عدد الاشتراكات
كلما زاد المشتركين كل ما أنت تستثمر أكثر في النقل
«بي إن» طبعًا حالة خاصة لأنها حكومية
فالحكومة هي اللي تدفع
ما تقدر تقول إنه والله هذا بحكم عدد المشتركين
بس حتى في الخارج، الهدف
من تحسين النقل، وعمل برامج، وعمل تحليل أقوى
وجذب محللين بأسماء أكبر؛ كل هذا استثمار
ولازم يكون بالمقابل فيه اشتراكات
فإذا ما فيه اشتراكات
يجي هنا القياس على حسب الجهة اللي متولية النقل
اليوم وزارة الرياضة هي اللي متولية النقل «إس إس سي»
وطلبوا منا أنه يكون فيه إشراف من فريق تقني من «إم بي سي»
إنه نرفع مستوى النقل
والحمدلله في الثلاثة أو أربع شهور الأخيرة
يمكن لاحظت أنه النقل تحسن كثير بالفترة اللي فاتت
وبيتحسن أكثر في الموسم القادم
بس لازال النقل مفتوح ماهو مشفر، ماهو تجاري بالمعنى
وهذا ما بيساعد في تطوير النقل التلفزيوني
لا يساعد، هنا عاد يرجع للجهة
الممولة لعملية النقل إذا بغوا يصرفون أكثر ممكن
بيرفعوا المستوى
يكون أفضل اللي ترفع المستوى أكيد
وعندك خيارات. أنت ممكن مثلًا اليوم «إتش دي» أو «4 ك» أو إن شاء الله «8 ك»
أنت تقرر نوع البرامج، نوع الضيوف اللي تجي بهم، المعلقين
قبل ما نقفل مرحلة دبي وننتقل لمرحلة رؤية 2030
نتكلم على صورة ذهنية عند المجتمع
أو عند شريحة من المجتمع عن «إم بي سي» بأنها القناة
اللي تنشر الانحلال، هي مشروع تغريب للمجتمع
المحافظين كانوا ولا يزالون منزعجين من «إم بي سي»
قناة الأطفال فيه تحذير شديد منها
وأنها أخطر ما يمكن أن يشاهده الإنسان هو قناة الأطفال
وحطوا مقطع لأحد البرامج اللي فيها قوس المطر
وإشاعة للشذوذ أو شيء مثل كذا
فأيش تعليقك على نظرة المجتمع المحافظ لـ «إم بي سي»
وسلوكها الغير مرغوب أو الغير المحبب من هذه الشريحة؟
أول شيء أنا أتحفّظ على المحافظين، أو المجتمع المحافظ
أنا أعتقد احنا كنا على سنوات طويلة
في صدام مباشر مع المؤدلجين ومع المتطرفين دينيًا
أكثر من ماهو قصة المحافظين
اليوم بيَّن واتضح أنه الحمدلله البلد كلهم محافظين
وعوائلنا اللي نعرفهم وأهلنا كلهم محافظين
ولكن ما هم متطرفين بالدرجة اللي كنا نواجه فيها من المجموعات هذه
ولكن برجع شوي وراء للحملات
الحملات ما كانت من جهة واحدة
كان خلفهم جيوش من دول متضررة من الـ «إم بي سي» ومن «العربية»
تدعم الحملات هذه
وهذا بعدين احنا اكتشفناه من أجهزة حكومية
بلغونا من وين المصادر تجي
وبعضها من نفس اللي حكيت لك عنهم قبل
اللي كانوا يبتزون دول الخليج في الماضي
وأصبحوا الآن عاطلين وما عندهم شيء
بس عندهم أساليبهم وطرقهم
ركبوا على موجة السوشيال ميديا الجديدة
فأي شيء يجي على الـ «أم بي سي» أو على «العربية»، تلقاهم يدعمونه
فكانت تجي من جهات مختلفة
وطبعًا بغض النظر من اللي يبدأ الموضوع، الباقيين كلهم وراه
بالنسبة لللي تحكي عنها مثلًا حقت قوس قزح
هذه اللي هي على «أم بي سي 3»
قوس المطر
إيه قوس قزح
الحين قوس قزح للأطفال، تعرف الأطفال معظم برامجهم فيها ألوان
وفيها قوس قزح، يعني هي الطفل في مرحلة ما قبل المدرسة
هذولا الصغار، معظم برامجهم هي أصلًا فيها الألوان، وما الألوان وكذا
لكن اللي صار جاءوا غيروا الصوت، وشالوا الصوت الموجود
وحطوا صوت يؤيد موضوع المثلية وما أعرف أيش على الفيديو هذا، ونشروه
وهو ماهو بهذا النص
لا طبعًا، رجعنا احنا للأصل، أبدًا الصوت واضح
اللي موجود ما له علاقة باللي طلع
فالناس تأخذ على اللي تشوف
اليوم ما عاده صوت
اليوم يقدر يجيبك أنت عمر بشكلك وبصوتك
ويخليك تقول اللي هو يبغاه ويطلعه للناس
فموضوع الذكاء الاصطناعي اليوم، وقد أيش ممكن يغير في الشكل وفي الصوت
ويخليك تقول كلام، وشفناه في مقاطع كثير
والتقنية موجودة وصارت متوفرة على مستوى الناس العاديين
بتطبيق في تليفونه يقدر يسويها
فخلنا نقول كانوا منظمين، وكانوا يقوموا بحملات مرتبة ومدروسة
ويضربون في «العربية» وفي الـ«إم بي سي» بطرق مختلفة
شيء مباشر وشيء غير مباشر
وما كانوا كلهم على فكرة على شكل لحى ورجال دين
كانوا بالعكس بعضهم يجي على شكل مهندس وعلى شكل دكتور، ولكن هو مؤدلج
بمعنى ميوله إخوانية، ميوله سرورية، ميوله ما أعرف أيش
يعني على حسب
وبدأوا يطلعون ويتكلمون
والحمدلله اليوم كلها هذه انكشفت للناس ما عاد هي سر
ولكن في نفس الوقت ترى على فكرة، ما يعني إنه «إم بي سي» ما تخطي
ترى في كثير من الأوقات يكون فيه خطأ
يكون فيه عمل طلع بشكل غلط
أعطيك مثال، أنا مثلًا
كان فيه مسلسل اسمه «ضحايا حلال»
عرضوه على «شاهد» من قبل سنة أو سنتين
وأتذكر كلموني عليه وقتها من وزارة الإعلام أنه في عمل
وأنا ما شفته الصراحة، بس طلبته وشفته
تضايقت كثير يوم شفته
لأنه نفى النص اللي كان موافق عليه من «شاهد» ومن الـ«إم بي سي»
كان معمول بشكل معين ومكتوب بطريقة معينة
التنفيذ كان بشكل مختلف تمامًا!
يعني الفكرة كانت أنه وحدة تتزوج واحد كبر ولدها، كذا مكتوب
هذا اللي كبر ولدها هي حرمة كبيرة، ماهي صغيرة
المفروض أنه يكون عمره 18 أو 19 سنة، وطالب في الجامعة
اللي نفَّذ راح وجاب ولد عمره 12 سنة أو 13 سنة صغير!
خير!
ومرَّت، وطلع العمل وظهرت الحلقة
هذا خطأ مافي الشك، وسحبنا المسلسل في لحظتها
وغيروه وحذفوا المشهد وأعادوا تصويره بالشكل الصحيح
فيصير أخطاء، وإذا صار؛ نعتذر ونسحب العمل ونتعامل معاه
بس لو بنقول «إم بي سي»؛ هل هي
توافق قيم المجتمع، تصادم قيم المجتمع
تحلِّق في قيم خاصة فيها، ولا لها دخل في المجتمع
أيش بيكون الخيار؟
أنا أعتقد الـ «إم بي سي» بدأت في مشوار
من بداية التسعينيات كانت سابقة اللي نشوفه اليوم
من منصات مثل «نتفلكس» و«ديزني»
اليوم احنا نشوف «الرجل العنكبوت» في «ديزني»
اليوم المثلية للأطفال، مو للكبار حتى
الناس لازم تعطيهم محتوى بديل
هل المحتوى البديل هذا محافظ أو غير محافظ؟
هذا موضوع أنا أعتقد يحكمون عليه الناس
أنا أتكلم على السواد الأعظم من الناس، ماهو على فئة معينة
واحنا راضين تمام الرضا عن ما يقدم في المجموعة
سواءً في «شاهد» أو في القنوات أو في الإذاعة
أو في كل المنصات اللي احنا مسؤولين عنها
ما عندنا أي تحفُّظ أبدًا
وبالعكس، أنا أعتقد اليوم الـ «إم بي سي» هي قناة العائلة بالدرجة الأولى
وهذا احنا نلمسه من المشاهدين بشكل مباشر الحمدلله
خلينا نقفل مرحلة دبي
احنا خلصنا لندن، مرحلة دبي، والآن نفتح مرحلة رؤية السعودية 2030
فيه حراك غير عادي في السعودية عمومًا
في ملف الإعلام والمحتوى والأبطال الوطنيين في قطاعاتهم
فمن أكثر من زاوية «إم بي سي» صار لها تقاطعات مع الرؤية
وصار لكم لقاء تاريخي مع الأمير محمد
خلينا نتكلم على «إم بي سي» في مرحلة الرؤية
أيش اللي صار في أول لقاء مع الأمير؟
أيش دوركم اليوم في رؤية السعودية 2030؟
شوف أنا سمو الأمير محمد، قابلته أول مرة عام 2014
كان رئيس ديوان ولي العهد الملك سلمان الله يحفظه
وجلست أنا وإياه، جلسة يمكن ساعة أو أكثر
كان منطلق فيها، وبنفس الوقت متضايق من بعض
الشغلات اللي كانت موجودة
واللي يمكن كثير كانوا مترددين في التعامل معها
وسمع مني عن تجربتنا وعن التوقعات
وأتذكَّر وقتها حتى طرح أنه أنتم ليش ما جيتوا السعودية؟
فشرحت له المعوقات وكذا
كان يسجِّل الله يحفظه
وبنفس الوقت
كان يقول أنه احنا يهمنا كثير أنكم تتوسعون، أنكم تكبرون
ونعتبركم جزء مكمِّل للرؤية اللي احنا راح نمشي فيها
أنا كان عندي شوي على الرؤية قبل ما تصير الرؤية
2018 لما جلسنا معاه كانت اتضحت الصورة أكثر
وبدأنا فعلًا نتكلم على أيش القطاعات
أيش التوجُّه اللي منطلقه فيه المملكة
وهذا طبعًا بالنسبة لي كان صدمة كبيرة يعني حلم
أيش قال لكم الأمير وقتها؟ أيش كان الحوار وعلى أيش في 2018 ؟
السعودية بلد شاب، فنسبة الشباب عالية جدًا من الجنسين
وهذولا لهم متطلبات
إن كان تتكلم عن الإعلام، الترفيه
كل القطاعات، المسرح، فعاليات، كل القطاعات تقريبًا
واحنا فقط مستقبلين
طيب متى احنا نقدر نصدِّر؟
متى احنا نقدر على الأقل نكتفي ذاتيًا لشعبنا في المملكة
وطبعًا بالنسبة لنا كان حلم بعيد جدًا
وبدأنا نلمسه، وبدأنا نشوف أنه هذا ممكن فعلًا يتحقق
هل حسيت أنه مهتم؟
يدعم المشروع، يوسع الآفاق في وين ممكن نوصل
وين ممكن نتخيل في قطاع الإعلام بشكل عام، وفي «إم بي سي» بشكل خاص؟
هل كانت هذه المساحة موجودة؟ أو كان نقاش تحديات بس انتقال للرياض؟
أنه كيف تنتقلون للرياض؟
لا أبدًا ولا كان، في 2018 ما كان فيه كلام حتى عن الرياض في ذلك الوقت
كان الكلام على هذه الصناعة كلها، وين رايحه؟
وكيف احنا نكون فاعل فيها؟
كجزء من الرؤية
هذه الرؤية، طبعًا هي الرؤية على كل القطاعات، بس هذا أحد القطاعات
كان أول شيء يسمع مننا، بعدين قام هو يعطينا
وهو كيف شايف التوجُّه
وقال أبدًا، أنتم طول عمركم تشتغلون قريبين من الحكومة
وبينكم وبين الحكومة علاقة وتكامل
فاحنا نبغى نطور هالموضوع بشكل أكبر
وأعطونا احتياجاتكم، كيف ممكن
طيب الحين لو افترضنا أنه
هذه الشركة اليوم بتكون جاذب
لبعض الكفاءات وبعض المواهب في السعودية مثلًا
كيف ممكن احنا نتوجه إلى أن نبتعث؟
بعض البنات والشباب في تخصصات أنتم تحتاجونها؟
أيش احتياجاتكم بالضبط في هذا المجال؟
وطلع منها شغلات كثير، من ضمنها «أكاديمية إم بي سي»
اليوم «أكاديمية إم بي سي»
اللي استفادوا من برامج «أكاديمية إم بي سي» 18 ألف شاب وشابة سعودية
اليوم فيه أحد الأعمال عندنا أعتقد فيه يمكن
300 شاب وشابة سعودية اللي يروحون
في فترات مختلفة، يشاركون في عملية الانتاج والتصوير
وشغلات ثانية مثل المكياج، الإضاءة، في كل المجالات
لكن هل بعد هذا اللقاء كبرت الأحلام ولا صغرت؟
أيش رؤيتكم بعد هذه الجلسة؟ هل اختلفت؟
اختلفت كثير
أيش اللي اختلف؟
اختلفت كثير لأنه اليوم صار الموضوع واضح بالنسبة لنا أكثر
تخيل أنت أنه من عام 1991
ومن بداية الـ «إم بي سي» من أول يوم واحنا ما نشوف إلا هنا
يعني تمشي أنت وتتخبط، ما تعرف بأي جدار بتصقع
لا فيه بث أرضي، قعدت على الدش، والدش يمنع وما يمنع
والبحرين وقفت، الكويت وقفت، المغرب وقفت
ما تدري كيف وضعك بيصير
لندن التكلفة ترتفع عليك من هنا
حتى بعد ما جينا دبي
برضها الرؤية ماهي واضحة 100%
اليوم أنت المعلن معاك
بكرة بدأ يطلع منتج آخر إعلامي راح اتجه له
اليوم احنا نعاني من «يوتيوب» و«فيس بوك» و«قوقل»
كل المنصات والإعلان على الإنترنت اللي يسحب
من محطات التلفزيون والإذاعة والمشاريع التقليدية
فهي الصورة ماهي دائمًا مبسطة وواضحة
كل يوم تلقى عندك تحدي مختلف وتحدي من هنا ومن هنا
فتتعثر وتقوم، وتتعثر وتقوم
بس اليوم اللي اختلف مع الرؤية
إنه لا، صار فيه توجُّه، وصار فيه عندك
جهات حكومية هنا تتعامل معها
عندها خطط طويلة الأجل
فعلى الأقل أنا أعرف من هنا إلى 2030 أيش بسوي
هذا كفاية بالنسبة لي
أيش تبغى توصل أنت بعد هذا اللقاء؟ وأيش صار الهدف؟
احنا إن شاء الله هدفنا أنه نشوف «إم بي سي»
من أكبر عشر كيانات إعلامية في العالم
وتقاطعاتكم مع الرؤية، ومشاريعها
شفنا اتفاقية مع «نيوم» في مجال غريب
ما تخيلنا أنه «إم بي سي» لها علاقة في موضوع الألعاب
وشفنا مع هيئة الترفيه مسرحيات ومشاريع وحفلات
وشفنا مع «القدِّية» أيضًا اتفاقية، ومع «الدرعية»
لو تلخص لنا أيش أهم المبادرات اليوم «إم بي سي» تساهم فيها من خلال الرؤية؟
«إم بي سي» تشتغل على عدة خطوط متوازية
المحتوى وتملُّك المحتوى أو الـ «آي بي» مثل ما يسمونه
على الألعاب، هذه الاتفاقية اللي عملناها مع «نيوم»
عملنا شركة
بدأنا في أول مشروع اللي هو «لعبة أيه أيه أيه» عن قصة «ألف ليلة وليلة»
هذا أول مشروع بدأنا فيه، بس احنا داخلين على مشاريع أخرى إن شاء الله في هذا المجال
الفعاليات، شغالين عليها الآن بشكل موسع وبشكل أكبر
شغالين على الـ «إي سبورت»، شغالين على الـ «أنمي»
بيننا وبين «القدِّية» شغالين حتى على
الـ «إم بي سي لوت» للإستوديوهات المفتوحة
هذه مو بس للـ «إم بي سي»، للـ «إم بي سي» ولأي أحد بكرة
يبغى ينتج سواءً من السعودية من الداخل أو سواءً من هوليود وغيرهم
اللي يبغون ينتجون في المملكة
أيش دخَّل هذه كلها في القناة؟ أنتم المفروض قناة
أيش دخلكم في هذه الأشياء المختلفة؟
لا، احنا الآن تعدينا من موضوع قناة
الآن استراتيجية «إم بي سي» هي شركة إعلامية ماهي فقط قنوات
احنا نوصل حتى إلى بعض الـ «آي بيز» إنها تكون ملاهي
على بعض الـ«آي بيز» اللي احنا نملكها
ويمكن مدام جينا على ذكر هذه المرحلة
فيه دائمًا تحفُّظ على الـ «إم بي سي» من ناحية تمكينها للشباب السعوديين
إنها قناة سعودية، بس السعوديين ما هم ممكنين فيها
كموظفين وكمنتجين، وهذه دائمًا تتكرر بشكل مستمر
فودي اسمع تعليقك عليها
والله شوف عمر، أنا أسمع طبعًا وأشوف في وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وأسمع بعض الأحيان حملات أو غيره على هذا الموضوع
بس لازم نرجع للأساس، الأساس «إم بي سي» هي ماهي شركة سعودية
هي ماهي شركة بالمعنى إنها تبث
أو إنها تشتغل داخل السعودية للسعودية
«إم بي سي» اليوم شركة عالمية
عندنا «إم بي سي» متواجدة في الدول العربية كافة بدون استثناء
متواجدة في أوربا، وأمريكا، وأستراليا، وأمريكا الجنوبية، وفي آسيا
للمشتركين في «شاهد» وفي أعمال «شاهد»
اللي هي موجودة باللغة العربية والإنجليزية والفرنسية، ثلاث لغات
فاحنا شركة عالمية أولًا وأخيرًا
لكن المكان، ووجودك في المكان أكيد
بيؤثر على الطريقة اللي توظف فيها
اليوم إذا أنا موجود في مصر أكيد بيكون نسبة المصريين عالية عندي
إذا أنا موجود في دبي مثلًا
بشوف مين الأرخص أو الأنسب أو الأكفأ
اليوم أنا فرضًا عينت سعودي وجبته على دبي
أيش تكلفته علي عشان يجيني في دبي؟
بينما أنا عندي يمكن أكفأ أردني أو مصري مثلًا أو لبناني
وموجود في دبي، بس ينتقل من مكان لمكان
وهو ساكن ومعه أهله أو لحاله
وتكلفته بتكون أقل علي
من هذه الناحية التجارية
الآن توَّنا منتقلين للسعودية، بوجودنا بالسعودية
مافي شك أنه نسبة السعوديين راح تكون أعلى بكثير
وخصوصًا بالمشاريع الجديدة
لأنه المشاريع الجديدة كلها متجهه لأعمار أقل وأعمار أصغر
والحمدلله السعودية اليوم توفر فيها
نسبة كبيرة من المواهب في هذه المجالات، ومن الكفاءات في المجالات هذه
أنا بعطيك مثال أنا مثلًا على معاناتنا مع السعوديين في السابق
يعني في التسعينيات
أنا أتذكر شباب سعوديين اشتغلوا معنا في ذاك الوقت
من عنف الهجمات اللي كانت
توجه للـ«إم بي سي» وغيرها
على فكرة حتى التلفزيون السعودي حتى الجرائد السعودية
أي شيء فيه هذا إعلام؛ كله ليبرالي، إعلام كله
إلى درجة أنه يكفرونه
مو بس كفروكم، أنتم صار دمكم حلال
إيه
استبيح دم ملاك القنوات فترة صح؟
صحيح
هذا أحد المشائخ
فتخيل، استقالوا!
عندنا شباب سعودي مثل الورد من أحسن ما يمكن
كانوا وكانوا مجتهدين وكانوا فيه
وسبب الاستقالة ضغوط من عوائلهم، من أهلهم
لأنه أهلهم ما تحملوا اللي يسمعونه
يجي في المسجد ويلقى واحد يخطب ويسب بالاسم كذا
فيقول هذا يسب الـ «إم بي سي» في المسجد وأنت تشتغل فيها!
أنا ما أقبل، لولده
فيحط ضغط على ولده نفسي أنه يترك
ويتركون، فيه كثير منهم تركوا
أضف عليها كيف كانوا الجامعات يرفضون تخصصات
اللي احنا كنا نحتاجها ذاك الوقت
سواءً في المسرح أو في الدراما أو في الإخراج
أو في الموسيقا أو غيرها
الموسيقا أصلًا هذه كلها حرام على بعضها وين ما تروح
البعثات الخارجية كانوا يرفضون التخصصات اللي لها علاقة في عملنا
كان فيه محاربة ممنهجة وسيطرة ممنهجة في قطاعات مختلفة
اللي تخرّج مواهب سعودية، فصار المتوفر محدود بالنسبة لكم
عشان كذا فيه ناس كثير مو مستوعبين التغيير اللي صار الحين
مو مستوعبين أيش معناة الرؤية
أيش معناة التغيير اللي الأمير محمد اليوم يسويه
والنقلة اللي تصير
هذه بتصير على كل المستويات
أعطيك مثال: الكرة
كيف أول النظرة للاعب الكرة؟
كان فيه تحقير للاعب الكرة، وكانوا أهله مستحيل يقبلون
أنه هذا يروح في المجال هذا، وحتى لو راح يعتبر شبه منبوذ من العائلة
اليوم يوم شفت أبطال العالم
وشافوا هذولا أيش المخصصات اللي يأخذونها
وأيش النقلة اللي نقلوا فيها عوائلهم وأهلهم، وبلدانهم كيف تفتخر فيهم
بدأت الصورة تتغير كثير
حتى الفنان التشكيلي، والطاهي والطباخ
الفنانين مثلًا
أنا مثلًا أعجبني معالي المستشار تركي آل الشيخ
في تكريم الفنانين السعوديين القدامى مثل بكر الشدقي الله يرحمه
محمد العلي، طلال مداح، محمد عبده
مسرح وحفلات تكريم لهم وتاريخهم
هذا شيء عظيم
الأمير بدر الفرحان في وزارة الثقافة، على رواد المسرح
وعلى الفنون كلها الفن التشكيلي وغيرها من الفنون
وتكريمهم والاهتمام فيهم
أنا أعتقد هذا ما كنا في يوم من الأيام نتخيل إنا نشوفه صراحة
من المآخذ برضه على «إم بي سي» موضوع
جودة الإنتاج الدرامي أو المسلسلات، وأنها ما تمثل المجتمع وما تشبه المجتمع
وكثير منها عليه كلفة عالية، بس مكرر نفس القصص ونفس الأحداث
وشيء ممل الناس ما تشعر بأنها تشوف شيء
يوازي حجم تكلفة الإنتاج اللي مثلًا متخيل عن مثل هذه الأعمال
أيش تقييمك لجودة الأعمال اللي تعرض
في «إم بي سي» وفي الإعلام العربي عمومًا؟
أنا بسألك أنت شفت «رشاش»؟
إيه شفته
أعجبك؟
بس هو الوحيد اللي أعجبني
ممتاز
هو المسلسل الوحيد اللي شفته ترى
ممتاز ممتاز، أنا وإياك أتفق
لأنه هذا اللي بتشوفه من الآن وطالع
ترى هذة النقلة، «رشاش» هو بداية الانتقال إلى المرحلة الجاية
أنت تتفق معنا أنه الإنتاج ما كان
لكن فيه سبب، أنا بعطيك السبب الآن
ليش «رشاش»؟ لأنه «رشاش» جاء مع انطلاقة «شاهد»
فيه عندك مشترك اليوم يدفع فلوس
مثل اللي يشتري تذكرة للسينما، فهذا أنا احترمه
هذا لازم أعطيه بالمستوى اللي هو يتوقعه
عشان يستمر معي وإلا بيطلع، مو بقاعد
الفرق أول لا، الفرق أنه أنا أحط أعمال للمعلن
المعلن ميزانيته محدودة، فأنا ما أقدر أجي أفرض على المنتج
سواءً اللي أنا أنتج الأعمال أو اللي منتج في الخارج يعملها
أنه يعملها بتقنية عالية، غير مجدية
بالآخير كيف أنا بمشِّي الجهاز الإعلامي اللي عندي؟
هذا إذا أكلفهم بأعمال أعلى من مستوى الدخل اللي ممكن يجيبونه
عشان كذا أقول لك اليوم احنا مثلًا مع نقلة «شاهد»
خلقنا كيان اسمه «استديوهات إم بي سي»
اللي عمل «رشاش» اليوم
فـ «استديوهات إم بي سي» اليوم إنتاجها فقط سيكون من هذا المستوى وأعلى
أيش فيه أعمال قادمة؟
شوف مثلًا بكرة بتشوف
على فكرة «قندهار»
«قندهار» من الأعمال اللي احنا اشتغلنا عليها على فكرة في «العُلا» وصوِّر في «العُلا»
فلم عالمي
«معاوية» عمل عظيم
في مستوى الأعمال الـ «إبك» العالمية
إن شاء الله بتشوفونه قريب
عندك فيلم الآن بنصوره في «القدِّية» في آخر السنة هذه
عن قصة بداية الإسلام
اللي قصة «الرسالة» القديمة اللي عملها مصطفى العقاد
ولكن احنا مآخذينها من زاوية أبوبكر الصديق
فاحنا مسمينه «الصدِّيق»
فاحنا مآخذين العمل من زاوية أبوبكر
تحبون المشاكل أبو خالد؟
بالعكس
ليش دائمًا الأعمال، يعني «رشاش» عمل ضجة
و أُوقف ثم أعيد. «معاوية» عمل ضجة
«الجابرية» أُوقف بالكامل
هل هذا نوع من تسويق الأعمال؟
وإلا «إم بي سي» تتعدى الخطوط؟
أيش تعليقك على سالفة
الصِدام اللي يصير مع كل عمل تنتجونه أو مع أغلب الأعمال؟
ذكرتني
حتى «عمر» كان عليه جدل على وقت الملك عبدالله
على الطاري على «عمر»
أنت ذكرتني يوم قررنا نسوي مسلسل «عمر» ذلك الوقت
رحت للملك عبدالله يرحمه، كان في روضة خريم
وقلت له، ترى عندنا فكرة نسوي
عمل وكذا عن قصة عمر
كان الملك عبدالله مهتم بقصة حوار الأديان ذاك الوقت
فقلت له أنه في العمل هذا إن شاء الله بيظهر
وهذا حقيقي ومؤرخ وموجود
قصة «عمر» كيف تعامل مع المسيحيين ومع اليهود
وأعطاهم من الزكاة. وهذا بيظهر
تحمس كثير وعجبته الفكرة
وقال لي أبد، توكلوا على الله
بس قلت شوف ترى بيهجمون
وترى بتسمع أشكال وألوان
ودي أنك قبل ما يوصلك، يكون عندك خلفية وتعرف أيش هذا
قال توكلوا الله
وبدأنا واشتغلنا طبعًا على الموضوع
أتذكر كنت في أسبانيا في ذاك الوقت
كان فيه صديق هناك، وقال لي ترى هذا الرجال يبغى يشوفك
وبيجي مخصوص عشان يقابلك
قلت الله يحييه، وجاء
يوم جاني، قال لي هذا العمل لازم يوقف
كيف؟
قال لي أبدًا هذا العمل مرفوض تمامًا من المؤسسة الدينية قاطبةً
وراح يجتمع هيئة كبار العلماء، وراح يصدرون بيان والعمل بيوقف
أحسن لك وقّفه من عندك
قلت له طيب على فكرة قطر مشاركيننا بالعمل
ترى إذا وقفته هم بيعرضونه
قال يعرضونه قطر، ولا تعرضه المنحطة «إم بي سي»
بالهجوم جاي بهذه الطريقة
وأنا ترى أنا ناصحٍ لك، ووقِّف العمل
لازم توقف العمل هذا
قلت خير إن شاء الله
طلع من عندي، وعُرض العمل واستقبل أحسن استقبال
الحمدلله في وقتها
وهذه النوعيات موجودة
وبتشوف بكرة في أعمال كثيرة، أكيد أصوات تطلع من هذه النوعية
لكن أحيانًا تستجيبون مثلًا «الجابرية» وقفتوه أو لا؟
لا «الجابرية» مؤقتًا
هل كان خطأ؟
لا ما كان خطأ، مؤقتًا
يمكن فيه شغلات بسيطة بس طلبت منهم أنهم يعيدون نظر فيها ويعدلونها
ولكن الإيقاف مؤقت، وكان بطلب من أخواننا في الكويت
ما كان له علاقة بالسعودية
على فكرة اليوم المملكة ووزارة الإعلام بالذات
وهيئة المرئي والمسموع من أفضل
الجهات الرقابية أو اللي ممكن
تلجأ لها في ترخيص أي إنتاج
أنا ودي أختم بآخر الجزئيات، وطولت عليكم أبو خالد آسف، بس مستمتع جدًا
أنا اليوم بتكلم مع الخبير مع المختص مع الرائد في هذا القطاع
أنت ذكرت في مقابلة لك قبل سبع سنوات
أنك أنت بنفسك تشوف الأعمال
وتقول إذا جاءتني أمور مالية وإدارية هذه ما أحبها وحولوها للمدير التنفيذي
فأنت تدخل حتى في موضوع المحتوى وإجازته
هل هذا صحي لحوكمة مؤسسة إعلامية؟
أو هذا هو الشغف اللي يدفعك لهذا الاتجاه؟
وأيش سر اقترابك من المنتج النهائي اللي يعرض على الشاشة؟
والله شوف أبو عبدالرحمن ترى أنا قريب
من المبدعين
أنا أحب أجلس معهم واسمع منهم، أنبسط
أنا استمتع
بس ما أفرض عليهم رأيي أبدًا بالعكس أتعلم منهم
وأكيد مع تراكمات من ثلاثين سنة تعلمت شغلات منهم
تخيل أنا أنتجت «عودة عصويد»
تعرف هذا عام كم؟
هذا يمكن عام 1986، ترى أول ما بدأت «آرا» في ذلك الوقت
كان محمد علي العلي الله يرحمه
وناصر القصبي وعبدالله السدحان كان توّهم بادئين ذاك الوقت
وراشد الشمراني ومجموعة كانوا
فمن ذاك الوقت واحنا نمر بتجارب مختلفة
وكل وقت طبعًا على حسب الوقت
فأنا عندي فعلًا شغف
أنا أحب لما أجلس مع الكُتاب، وبعدين مع المخرج
ويعطوني تصوراتهم وبعض الأحيان يشاوروني في شغلات
خاصة إذا هي سعودية، أو خليجية خلنا نقول
والمخرج أو هذولا من أجانب أو عرب
فيه بعض التفاصيل ما يعرفونها، احنا نجتمع ونعطيهم
بعض الخلفيات، بعض التفاصيل
هذا يصير وهذا ما يصير، هذا ينقال وهذا ما ينقال، من هذه الشغلات
أو مع الكُتاب بعد
أحب هذا الجانب أكثر
بس ما يخرِّب الحوكمة أنه فيه فريق المفترض أنه هو يجيز المحتوى ويتابعه
إذا الرئيس معانا وقال لنا تمام، الفريق ما عاد له دور
لا، هذا أنا أقعد معهم بعد ما يخلصون
تمام
هذولا كانوا خلاص انتهوا وأعطوا اللي عندهم كله
يجونا احنا في شغلات بسيطة اللي يصير
أو أقولهم توكلوا على الله
فدائمًا أقولهم تعاملوا معاي أني أنا العميل
يعني لا تعتبروني الرئيس
أنت تمثل المشاهد
إيه أنا اللي مكلفكم بالعمل، أنا شاري العمل منكم
فخذوا وجهة نظري من هذه الناحية ومن هذه الزاوية
مو أني رئيسكم
يعني لا تخذونها من
يعني خذوا وأعطوا معي
قولوا لا هذه نبغاه وهذا نقبل فيه وهذا ما نقبل فيه، عادي
فيه هنا سؤال على موضوع قادة الإعلام السعودي
أغلب الإعلام العربي الناجح اليوم
تلقاه نوعًا ما مملوك من سعوديين أو أسسوه سعوديين
ففيه إكتساح
لكن لما نجي نتكلم على الأثر
على التأثير على الشعوب
على خدمة مصالحنا
ما يبدو الموضوع يعكس حجم وجودنا في هذه الصناعة
ليش الإعلام السعودي ما هو مؤثر؟
سؤال أنا أعتقد جدًا مهم
هذا يعكس السياسة السعودية
السياسة السعودية عمرها ما حاولت إنها تؤدلج أحد
أو أنها تغير فكر أحد
أو أنها تتدخل في شؤوننا
أنا قلت لك الملك عبدالله لما بنعمل «العربية»
يقول خلهم كلهم يجون ويشاركوننا
غلط كلمة الإعلام السعودي
احنا ما نعتبر نفسنا إعلام سعودي، احنا إعلام عربي
اليوم «إم بي سي مصر» تنافس القنوات المصرية كلها بمصريتها
ماهو بأنها سعودية، بمصريتها
والعاملين فيها كلهم مصريين
وهي القناة الأولى في مصر بنسب المشاهدة
هي قناة مصرية، وقناة «إم بي سي العراق» قناة عراقية
واللي فيها عراقيين، اللي يعملون فيها كاملين
ما فيها سعودي واحد يشتغل فيها
فالسعودية عمرها ما كانت بلد
لا تتدخل في شؤون الأشقاء والدول العربية الثانية
بالعكس إذا ما ساعدت؛ ما تضر
فيه وجهة نظر للسعودية
نعم وجهة نظرنا معلنة ومعروفة واحنا ننقلها
بس ما نفرضها على أحد
فهذه بالعكس تعكس
احنا خلفيتنا وخلفية المملكة العربية السعودية
ولو بختم بسؤال على موضوع
خبرتك وتجربتك ثلاثين سنة لو بتهديها لشاب
أو مؤسس لكيان إعلامي، أو شخص مهتم بالإعلام
بعد هذه الثلاثين سنة، أيش أهم الدروس اللي تعلمتها؟
أو أهم درس وتحب تهدي للعاملين في هذا القطاع
أو الرواد العمال أو الشباب المهتمين في القطاع؟
أنا دائمًا أحاول أنصح عيالي أنه أسمع أكثر مما تحكي
مثلًا حكينا عن بيل كلينتون يوم كان يقول لي على الإنترنت
والطريق السريع، ووين رايحة الدنيا
هو يحكي، وأنا أفكر أيش المواضيع اللي أبغى أطرحها معاه
وأراجع الشغلات اللي في رأسي أبغى أقولها
ما كنت مركز كثير على هذا الكلام إلا بعدين
يوم شفت نتائجه فعليًا
لو أنا أخذته بجدية؛ كان يمكن أضاف لتجربتي كثير
وعجَّل نقطة التعادل، وعجَّل الانتقال
ويمكن بعد كان دخلنا في مجالات أخرى استفدنا منها
مع النقلة اللي صارت مع دخول الإنترنت في ذلك الوقت
من بداية التسعينيات
وبنفس الوقت
التقنية تتغير بشكل سريع جدًا
أيش الثابت أجل؟ إذا التقنيات والوسائل تتغير؟
بالنسبة لمجالنا المحتوى
المحتوى راح يكون مطلوب بغض النظر عن التقنية
اليوم نظارة «الأبل برو» أظن اسمها
ممكن تخليك تشوف الفيلم مثل أعظم شاشة سينما مثلًا
هل هذا يلغي الفيلم؟ لا
الفيلم راح ينشاف مثل ما كان يشوفه في السينما بينشوفه هنا
ومثل وكما كان يشوفه في التلفزيون سابقًا
مثل ما كان يشوفه، لكن
لا، هي هنا تجربة السينما
هو دخل على تجربة السينما أكثر
بالصفاوة، بالنقاوة، بالصوت، بالصوت المحيط
يعطيك هذه التجربة
حتى يمكن يكون ثلاثي الأبعاد أو رباعي الأبعاد
هذا اللي أنا فهمته من العرض اللي عملوه
بس هذا بيؤثر على دور العرض
وليس على صناع المحتوى، لأنه المحتوى بيشوفه هنا أو هنا
بس دور العرض بتتأثر
بدل ما يروح ويأخذ تذكرة ويدخل ويشوف الفيلم
لا، ممكن يشوفه هنا
فالمحتوى هو الباقي
المحتوى، والـ «آي بيز» بشكل عام
أساسية بالنسبة للي يشتغل في هذا المجال
«بلومبيرق» تقول أنكم تطرحون السنة هذه اكتتاب عام
نقدر نشتريه؟ ولا بتوزعونه علينا بلاش؟
احنا كل الاحتمالات مطروحة للمستثمرين
أو شراكات أو كلها مطروحة
وإلى الآن ما عندنا شيء، ما في قرار شيء نعلنه
بس كيان ربحان أنتم
احنا كيان تجاري ربحان
واليوم عندنا توسعات كبيرة
حتى لو بيصير فيه
مشاركات أو غيرهم ممكن ما يكون على كل المجموعة، على جزء من المجموعة
مثل ما دخلنا بشراكة مع «نيوم» في موضوع الألعاب
فكل الاحتمالات مطروحة
شكرًا لك أبو خالد، شرفتنا ونورتنا
الله يحفظك
ممتن لوقتك
الله يحفظك يا أبو عبدالرحمن
الله يعطيك العافية
شكرًا لكم. وشكرًا لفهد القصير في إعداد وإنتاج هذه الحلقة
ياسر آل غانم في إضافة التصوير
ياسر كدشة مساعد إضاءة
وفي تصوير الكواليس عبدالرحمن عبود
في تسجيل الصوت عبدالعزيز المزي
وفي الإخراج الفني مجد القرشي
وفي التحرير أنس الخليل
وفي الهندسة الصوتية محمد الحسن
وفي التلوين عبدالمجيد العطاس
وفي الإشراف على الإنتاج غيداء التميمي وأصيل بافرط
هذا بودكاست «سقراط»
أحد منتجات شركة «ثمانية» للنشر والتوزيع